une production du studio
sfb nido a lancé mme filtré la pratique
est ce qu'on parle de ce qu'on veut
faire chanter avec moi dôme plantes gars
sur notre page pétrin en ce moment je
vais pas tout les nommer mais on a
beaucoup de podcasts qui sont là en
avance déjà des podcasts ce que nous on
prend des vacances dans le mois de
janvier fait qu'ils aient toutes nos
podcasts du beau johnny qui sont déjà
disponibles sur pet hui han et ouïgours
trois pièces par mois vous avez déjà
accès à tout ça en plus d'avoir accès à
l'est encore moins de physique parce
qu'après chaque podcast on discute on
jason ingham on
[Musique]
est aujourd'hui
puis ça s'est excusé au match aller voir
sinon cette semaine cette semaine le
grand bateau de type stop c'est sa
quatrième fois par une pause car elle y
est venue plusieurs fois ça nous inviter
fétiche on adore s'entraîner avec lui on
a beaucoup de choses en commun accord
avec des on l'a attrapé de justesse à
son volant impression de retour
d'occupation 2 alors
on a parlé de la vie live live a parlé
cet automne et disent qu'ils sont très
en profondeur ses réflexions sur la vie
sous votre nez rendu là on est tous à
l'aube de la trentaine à peine de trente
ans les 3 mai et puis c'est des grands
questionnements donc si vous avez déjà
eu 30 ans où vous aurez un jour 30 ans
peut-être que ce qu'ils sont là où bon
vous rejoindre on a parlé de sa relation
avec
son travail d'animateur à rodez de
parler de
l'entraînement de parler de course j'ai
pris sa roue de secours g qui compte de
plus en plus on ne parlait de trouver
son chez soi
c'est toujours très - chansons tout en
discutant avec jim a nourri inspiré et
ça fait pas exception à la règle
aujourd'hui tout à fait c'est vraiment
l'fun à chaque année on a pris comme
l'espèce de tradition de voir jay
injustement décembre souvent le puits à
chaque année on fait un check up du wpt
est ce qu'on est rendu tout le temps
extrêmement agréable juste avant de vous
laisser avec le podcast on va les
remercier nos commence par nous
le podcast de cette semaine et présenté
encore une fois par nos amis chez même
skate
on vous parle souvent du perfect paquet
4.0 qui en toute honnêteté le paquet
ultime pour l'entretien sur la ceinture
mais maintenant je vous parlais du body
wash et du shampoing de en main
revitalisant shampoing avec leurs
fragrances signature
realtime est la même que dans leur part
falls et vegan c5 route et est moins
honnêtement c'est maintenant mais de
produits préférés lors de ma douche en
fait je vous encourage grandement à
lecce que ceux ci n'ont dormi ont
d'autres tags et de fait je vous invite
à les regarder à quoi tu mens qu'il ya
vraiment toute une palette de produits
puis elle adore aller pour choisir que
ce qui est parfait pour vous vous
connaissez le projet de paquets 7.0 avec
le le fameux radwa électrique qui vient
la date est aussi le coach smooth
banquette comme j'aime beaucoup question
sera en fête ont leurs rasoirs là bas et
trois lames azor super bien fait pour
rose et nos parties intimes qui ont avec
c'est un gel on a un exfoliant en est
l'âme de remplacement est aussi le grand
choeur oui le wac le world wide web les
poils dans les voiles donné oui vraiment
avec avec masque et pompeux avant la
visite est la plus parfaite que vous
n'aurez jamais eu de votre vie et la
propreté aussi un petit vraiment aidé r
ouais on a un cas vraiment pour vous
sans filtre en un mot 20% rabbin
shipping gratuit
mindscape maîtrise
le podcast aujourd'hui est présenté par
omis laboratoire qui belles entreprises
d'ici fondée par deux jeunes femmes dans
la vingtaine qui ont fait le guidera nos
jeunes excepté qui sont les plus vieux
et c'est une compagnie des skins qui en
compagnie de produits pour la peau de
crème de cerrone et de tout ça et c'est
super le fun parce que pendant les
connaître tous les produits tout c'est
ce qu'on a eu besoin de savoir quand on
achète des crimes on avait besoin de pas
le quiz sur leur site dans lequel vous
rentrez votre type de peau dans lequel
vous rentrez vos préférences et vous
recevez les produits c'est sur mesure
pour vous il ya plus de 4000
combinaisons possibles puis mme dumont a
essayé en fait de faire le quiz et nous
a envoyé des produits vraiment
personnalisé pour nous honnêtement moi
j'ai jamais pris vraiment soin de me
promener m'envoyer un savon en fait pour
laver mon visage avec un sérum une crème
de jour et une crème de nuit
carrefour vrai j'ai pris la routine qui
se rend pas quelque chose que je faisais
avant que je le fais honnêtement dans
toute transparence le fais tout le temps
au matin et au soir je me lave le visage
me mets mon sérum j'applique mon ces
référentiels mais ma crème soit de jour
ou de nuit et je me sens presque blanc
dise je me sente simply j'ai pu d'acné
moi je faisais des boutons des fois un
peu partout dans la barbe le cc partie
parce que je lave ma peau honnêtement
allait faire le test à l'est par le quiz
qui a profité de notre code promo qui le
sans-fil pro 15 en un mot pour 15 % de
rabais ça vaut vraiment la peine dit
votre peau vous n'en avez juste une
faute a dit faire attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais c'est quand même facile aussi me
fascine c'est que j'ai c'est une
invention humaine l'argent c'est
sûrement cela ça me fascine parce qu'il
faut chaque homme s'est vraiment rendu
compliqué aujourd'hui acheter des choses
de commandes les les maisons que tu as
dit que tu pars chef c'est quand même
oui mais on l'inventé comme sonné comme
les pokémon sabres affirmer notre ferme
volonté qu'ont jamais l'argent c'est ce
mais ça a marché
fonctionne la société fonctionnait
autour des pokémon
[Rires]
banon mais parce que techniquement il si
on le fait une fois on est capable de
leur frère avait justement tout ça
existe peu plus que l'argent non c'est
ce que je sais
on peut leur faire encore fixée pour ce
que je me dis braga qui est peut-être la
crypto cécile et jean mais en même temps
ça m'intéresse tellement pas que j'ai eu
comme pas envie de prendre la peine de
l'homme et l'informé jeu très
divertissant par les gens qui essayent
de m'expliquer ce que c'est parce qu'à
chaque fois les hommes à risque comme
essayent juste voir comment tu vas t'y
prendre je comprendrais pas j'ai
divertir tout le monde a conversation
sur ma raison explique moi c'est comme
si j'avais cinq minutes les bleus
peuvent maintenant acheter
une oeuvre d'art virtuelle c'est sûr il
existe juste une fois toutes les
certitudes que la vraie vie les gens
riaient de moi qui ont acheté genre des
bateaux virtu georges un bateau mais ils
virtuels mais j'en viens à justin c'est
moi qui le csb ce parce qu'elle est et
facebook qui devient metteur programme
on veut créer des lieux virtuels dans
fond ce que tu veux c'est un bord comme
si ce que tu veux mais tu veux pas la
voir comme ça je trouve ça des fois les
écoute parler je fais sont tellement
pris dans leur monde j'ai l'impression
qu'à parce que justement pris d'animaux
si le mais que c'est comme un de vos
bord
moi ça me créer de l'anxiété au plus
haut point et penser à ça on a reparlé
que de passer par casse mais comme qui
cloche que
facebook charger nom prometteur pour
faire un environnement comme 100%
virtuel avec l'ofppt genre pour
reconnecter comme ça mais j'en on l'a
juste connectés quoique de manière
organique le genre rassemblez vous dans
un lieu comme avant ça marche et c'est
qu'en plus la dépassant même plus gène
camion appelé sa maîtresse est comme ca
/ cacher ce que man on a le fossé sépare
le concert vol ok
mais c'est la piste encore une fois
c'est que je fais je comprends
l'efficacité de la patente et je
comprends comment ça peut faire québec
un enfant qui étudier à l'extérieur peut
parler que ses parents virtuellement
je comprends tout ce qui peut
fonctionner la dame et des fois la mara
qui en parlent comme si c'était comme la
manière dont l'avis de ses calmes aux
attentes cc c'est vraiment intense je
trouve le tpiy c'est comme
celle tellement le fun juste
rencontré
au bowling ces résultats à ceux ci
mettons le quai qu'un lucky tard enfin
une vie ça y va jamais de dire mettons
j'aurais dû plus travailler ou jeu
résulté être plus devant mon ordi ce
tout le temps les connexions humaine
sous tend ce qui reste du temps ce qui
est comme quand tu prends du recul tout
comme ses plus importants sur les
relations est bien évidement les de son
matériel outre les relations plus c'est
comme on veut remplacer sa part genre
comme la chose la chose comme la plus
importante comment on s'entend que c'est
comme sur l'essentiel c'est comme lire
elle les relations entre humains et
comme on vous rend ce virtuel j'en
voulais je sais pas tu apprécies sais
que ça peut aller tellement loin en
forme et en même temps je décède points
mais que mon avatar existe est ce que
dans le fond tu perds tu continues de
continuer c'est que tu comprends c'est
que ce
niveau effrayant mais ces sommes mais
j'ai toujours dit ça j'ai toujours dit
que ce qui me faisait le plus peur
maintenant dans le cinéma cjce a jamais
téléfilm de rom et cd films de science
fiction parce qu'ils testent f on
n'était pas seulement capable de se
projeter puis de voitures et on me
rappelle la première fois éjecté
bladerunner l'original blade runner avec
harrison ford jeu j'étais terrifiée
parce que parce que ça commence puis moi
je les ai vus bien plus tard que sa
sortie était gelée vu comme
fin 2000 puis
c'était trop proche de genre les images
qui nous venaient de comme shanghai et
le type de grosses métropoles asiatiques
le sait comme des gros billboard qui
bouge puis des espèces de une espèce de
l'ambiance steampunk puis je me rappelle
ma dit on est proche de celui des robots
qui commencent à ressentir genre longue
on le voit maintenant le texte entraîne
de soi ça crie ça me fait peur qu'on
dirait que ça ça me fait le même même
feeling d'un camion c'est cool fm ce qu
est ce qui me fait le plus peur même si
wallin worli wali le futur de walle là
je suis
qui sont ces genres assez sont
constamment connecté sur un écran
constamment divertis par un million d'ha
farion pillon plus de connexion ils se
parlent plus genre et bouge plus il
bouge plus la terre est comme
apocalyptique lui apparaît et invivable
qui se susurre le et comme
vous êtes droit car c'est comme la seule
fois de ma vie que j'habite est seule à
montréal souvent après les choses
rentrent ippj écouter la télé et la
seule fois de ma vie que j'ai arrêté
quelque chose parce j'avais pas seuls
visés
un adulte a
eu une heure du matin j'écoute
blackberry c'était l'épisode où le gars
est vraiment jaloux de sa blonde puis tu
peux voir genton passé comme si tout ce
que tu vis tu peux leur écoute et
puis finalement il y avait raison mais
comme la scène s'était même pas cinq ils
faisaient pas une scène où la tension
était tellement forte comme c'était
tellement tendue que moi j'étais comme
pubiens j'ai arrêté je définis le
lendemain matin au soleil
[Rires]
guy wilks qui commence à entourer de
gens je pense qu'ils ont somme toute des
discours similaire au nôtre en ce moment
avec des teams aussi chaud dans ma bulle
entourée de beaucoup d'artistes
de beaucoup de gens qui travaillent dans
ce milieu où qu'ils habitent terre
qui ont cette espèce de ping-pong
l'homme a précisé comment mais il ya
juste une bulle - avec les autres bulles
sont vraies c'est fait que je sais plus
si étoffe je trouve aussi des
algorithmes de tout de suite le fait que
ces quêtes on se ramasse tout isolé dans
notre monde à nous puis on dirait que la
communication entièrement nu des fois
être un peu complexe une version pc dans
cette idée le précise de ce qu'on parle
ya vraiment deux idées conflictuelles
tout comme la tendance deux des jeunes
générations à vouloir déconnecter mais
inversement latence aussi d'une autre
gagne de notre génération à vouloir
ultra-connectés le jeu par la méthode
aller dans le dans le le métal bull ce
fx est comme deux idées vraiment
distingue plus on est au mieux de se
dire bon mais ce que j'ai est-ce que
dans le fond je vais m'acheter un chalet
en estrie sur le bord d'un lac ou est ce
qu'il n'ya pas eu de white foil ou
est-ce que j'embarque dans la crypte
romane
qui est devant moi le com est depuis le
milieu de la réponse est vraiment au
milieu mais en même temps
il y en as tu vraiment un milieu leur
mac ça s'articule la nuance existe de
moins en moins c'est sa soeur aussi tpiy
moi j'suis le premier à venir de thé je
pense que ce qui me fait découvrir mais
ça a été les réseaux sociaux moi ça me
faut l'aider et aujourd'hui je reprends
m'en détacher papa je suis content mais
je ça me rappelait plus comme ça me
remplit cet effet pu aussi positif que
ça l'était mais l'oeil ya une partie de
moi
à chaque fois je vois un plan d'eau j'ai
envie de lancer mon téléphone
on a tous cette espèce de
voir que m6 fait c'est ma vie continue
mais réforme que dc mais j'ai des fois
il essaie de ne pas brancher mon fils
l'a le plus longtemps possible c'est le
monument classé comme acquis mais en
fait
c'est super compliqué c'est ce panier
jamais ton chez nous j'ai des speakers
sonos et snap question
dans ma propre maison mon seul peuple et
demain je peux même pas écouté ma
promise et que c'est super niaiseuse
cefac lincecum a ma gueule et c'est
drôlement fait parce que c'est super
confortable ce qui se met en pratique je
suis pas en pratique marcelo ebard c'est
comme si je suis dépendant de tu peux
écouter la musique chez nous mais c'est
quand même un mais comment je fais je
serais même acheté un flip phone juste
pour être comme alors que je connais
aussi je peux juste travailler ma
discipline pis mais on est sur la drogue
à force il pas dû c'est la fin mais il
ya moyen d'être de le faire si justice
est comme ces mets particuliers j'ai
essayé de faire le jeune intermittent
des écrans aux bravos aucun ce que
j'avais mais ça va pas durer c'est sale
c'est cette musique a laissé faire ce
genre dans les bleus domenech
j'habitais easy commencé multi
vite en
fac c'est
vraiment
pour lui des crises émission je vais
essayer de le lire mais tant pis le
matin mais ton tu me réveille un peu
avant 8h active pour première fois que
je fais du démon sel je me levais être
humain normal je vais la méthode manger
tu es tu arrivé matin ce nom mais c'est
sûr que si ça va pas durer mais moi
c'est ça c'est ça ça me ça fait deux ans
maintenant que je dis
je le fais pas par où ça passe mais
aussi comme j'aime sommes réveillés
qu'un petit homme tranquille mais là
c'est quand même mais c'est sûr que ça
existe grogner je le verrai le mapaq dit
ce qu'il fait mais c'est comme un
système facile tellement pratique sous
la manche mais s'acheter un fils charger
iphone juste plus long que je peux être
couché c'est comme ça comme non faut pas
ça je vais le mettre ailleurs c'est
super et c'est super bizarre si
mais si je pense vraiment que
même moi j'ai de la misère tc puis je
vois maintenant voici que j'ai un
réflexe différent j'ai longtemps
justement tout ce qui arrive est ce
qu'elle mange à mettre une photo de toi
même et tu es devenu merci c'est pas
facile pour moi je suis fou limite
médiatisé l'automne je suis sûr toutes
les écrans facile toujours de potes que
mettre le paquet si je veux pas savoir
que tu es dans le vrai que c'est super
facile pour moi pressé de faire est
déconnecté son nom était signé notre
contrôle
facile
notre saison
des dunes wantzenau lancé un bruit parce
que dans trois mois tu sais que tu vas
être faut-il médiatisé était fatigué
mais je suis quand même curieux de
gélules et de mathieu mais quand les
riches ya pas longtemps
gravés les noms je vais pas lui mais je
ça m'a mené mais j'écoutais magic mike
segar
[Rires]
bien pauvre froidement des
pays mais il
lui jacques magne étaient tannés de d'en
savoir toujours les offres de deux
comédies romantiques
lui c'est will de 28 à 31 ans il y avait
déjà fait son gros hits populaires le
fils zen comme des interviews ça a été
son premier abbas avait fait un film que
ça ne le bloque et une histoire de john
grisham un livre que john grisham écrit
et lui jouaient l'avocat fait là c'est
devenu comme une vedette pas plus
d'après ce il s'est mis à faire des roms
comme et de 28 à 31 ans j'habitais d'une
vanne avec son chien partout state
ainsi à fin février eh bien il qu'à y
avait des contrôles y aller en charge
des meetings des foyers t'es qu'un mac
et 20,2 me tais toi je vais te cherches
à te l'aéroport de malé de porte à
l'autre aéroport à votre arrivée pour
josé a rempilé y habiter y aller il ya
des campings des affaires alors que
c'était déjà une joie de vedettes les
puis j'ai trouvé intéressant qui fait ça
puis après ce quart ils étaient tannés
d'abord que des offres de rome comme à
manier fait piller et puis j'aime ça me
ça m'a beaucoup rassuré avec aude et de
lire ça parce que repos ma réflexion par
rapport au style est constante 1008ha
contre m il consomme depuis le début la
première minute qui a offert la première
saison jacques puis je pense que c'est
correct et de garder une réflexe que moi
c'est la mena que je fonctionne maman
met du temps pour ce tome en question
mes gardes je suis fils demain puis lui
longtemps était commun et c'est quoi les
roms comme ça me rend de bonne humeur ça
fait que je vis une vie confortable je
pratique mon métier puis je diverti les
gens pendant une heure et demi déjà ils
pensent pas à leurs problèmes et
puis voyez ce de manière somme toute
assez simple quand même un travail
permanent tech a manqué c'est plus
suffisant ça ne nourrit plus assez
créativement fait pendant 20 mois il
refusé toutes les offres ont été
offertes parce que c'étaient tous des
oeuvres de rome comme un point où il ya
des kids après ces caisses qui
manquaient pas d'argent le mets un point
où c'est comme est très inconfortable de
dire non à tout jusqu'à temps que les
offres intéressantes débarque et ça
prive un mois maintenant à maxi of la
rive puis le bel adam lui avait déjà
acheté c'est lui qui avait acheté le
film qui en fait est que jean marc
vallée
de la reuss classé lui liste est
rattachée au scénario puis en fait ça
avec 5.4 millions là c'est vraiment pas
beaucoup de l'enfant de riez et jean
marc gales est également créée sans
raison si ça c'est complet justement 180
ses séquelles quelle meilleure façon que
deux personnes est si drôle de mec
incroyable gagne en h cup c'est quand
même et le chul genre les journaux et
nos métiers mettons à leonardo et brad
pitt se situe dix acteurs qui étaient
comme étiqueter les bourgault genre
depuis qu'ils ont fait des choix
vraiment audacieux pour comme briser un
peu ceux de ne pas atteindre cette image
le 2 comme juste les moyens le bel
acteur les coins c'est ce qu'il faut
faire ce choix le sommes tout à un
moment où dans leur position j'imagine
qu'ils étaient éliminés une vie
confortable mais c'est inconfortable
pareil des fois de refuser des offres
intéressantes oui c'est fait qu'il ya
tout ça aussi ça prend comme une forme
de courage le jeu mais des gros
guillemets ici non sans talent mais
c'est
aux longues terme finalement c'est
tellement payant mais
vous avez 15 30 si ça en a eu 30 ca ca
dessus saviez tue soit je tue quelque
chose d
aussi j'ai eu 30 autant ça vous situe
surpris vous attendiez-vous à avoir des
réflexions différents moi je me rappelle
quand j'ai eu 30 le mot je vais avoir 31
en janvier mais quand j'ai eu 30 l'année
passée je me rappelle ces moyens
là tourner les étoiles flamme des
cowboys fringants que j'adore quelle
anecdote qui passe
le deuxième est dans la trentaine de la
bédaine les morveux l'hypothèque oui là
c'est comme
je me regardais un miroir à 30 en plus
en plus l'année passée c'est peut-être
le moment de ma vie où est ce que je
t'ai comme le moins en shape le depuis
un bout mais ton puis le jeu ne seraient
admis rod je fais toi afin d'être sûr à
courir en bas 3,0 marathon je te le dis
qu'il a apprécié on va régler les aux
affaires parallèle à ta vie mais ça
c'est la chose principale que tu vas
faire parce que sinon ça marche europol
sinon tu t'en as ligne pour la trentaine
la bedaine et mon ampli quoi
s'attendent pas pantoute
après ce qui s'est passé c'est que dans
le processus pour faire ce
j'ai commencé commencé à recentrer
plusieurs autres affaires dans ma ville
et y mettons à mettre plus d'énergie sur
le studio a en voyant qui a créé le
studio c'est comme une une avenue de
genre peau stabilité mais une avenue de
com de stabilité dans le fond une tique
va me permettre de pouvoir bild est sur
quelque chose puis de mettre des
fondations solides puis on dirait que le
déclic s'est fait de juste le 15 janvier
la journée m'a fait dans le miroir
affaire trouve en tabarnak sur vos potes
va pas d'en sortir de même le niveau
pour réussir à jouarre vieillir comme
sur pizarro après c'était un gars de
discipline parce qu'il fait après os est
ce exact sauf que non mais c'est ce que
cela déclenche et principalement peu
apprécié j'ai commencé à remettre en
place ma vie morceau par morceau
m'attendent oui toi ça fait ça aussi
c'est du vol mais c'est la première fois
j'ai longtemps été le plus jeune partout
ouais je suis en septembre 5 à l'école
je t'ai toujours d'un plus jeune oie qui
jetaient tout jourdain plus jeunes
souvent été le plus petit le plus mais
gainey m même quand j'ai commencé à
faire de l'humour mais je rentre à
l'école de l'humour à 19 ans sortie de
l'a21 fait que commencer à faire des
shows des jeunes du panier à 25 c'est
incroyable ces jeunes ne sais quoi le
voit le spectre hante le site allemand
s'est quand même année le
gym enfin je suis vraiment plus le plus
jeune partout le ter presse le milieu
toute seule espèce de sa première fois
que justement je me disais est ce que ça
fait trop longtemps que je fais mettons
une geek comme mode et parce que
tout le temps du monde l'attendait et
attend le moi je veux pas
parce que tu crées de l'espace ou six
ans en quittant des projets comme ça où
les vérités du crédit créé des
opportunités comme vous avez fait le
studio vous avez créé quelque chose qui
crée une espèce de motion qui chacun à
faire mais dans un autre des noms autant
dit oui c'est des trucs que tu refuses
to créé de l'espace jacqueline un mois
ça prendra faut que je t'ai khama qui
attend mais je n'ai pas j'ai jamais tu
es nerveux avec le fait de vieillir tant
que ce
petit mes parents sont jeunes et il ya
aussi le tir mes amis que l'appareil
photo peut plus vieux le tu vois que
l'on rencontre ces conseils ne les avait
jamais eu de pression c'est d'avoir des
enfants avec sait pas tout ce temps j'ai
une maison j'ai en charge travail mais
c'était plus un espèce de thé au shit
atteint le thé la vie passe le genre je
parle que j'entends mes parents le
plafond est ici ça va vite ça va vite ça
mais c'est clair ça va vite ça n'a pas
de bon sens arrêté un mois sa plus était
seule espèce de la constatation du temps
qui passe de voir que amo pis des
bocages ça fait dix ans qu'on est amis
du coin
4 levac qui a eu ses bébés et les ces
commentaires mercato qui connaît les
codes et le monde le sait comme le sait
comme ailleurs aux plus des mêmes la
forêt
à la lettre depuis lors je parle à
modérer nos petits comme des croûtons ni
qui sont alors c'est quoi ces sketches
le mais en même temps près de gratitude
face à l'eau j'en suis mais c'est ça a
vraiment été une relation avec le temps
qui est comme une espèce d'urgence
réalisé que ça existait ouais ouais moi
tu vois c'est l'atout de huit secondes
j'ai réalisé qu'il reste plus de la
dame 30 ans ouais mot 30 ans et ça c'est
plus que ça mais en fait c'est vraiment
une vie prépare des mines vie et passe
par lesmills complètement différentes
qui lèverait seuil et
damas dans ma vingtaine j'ai été j'ai
faut le fait de choses il faut le fait
de jeter comme à fond la caisse puis
j'ai une blonde pendant longtemps plaie
c'est comme ça ça finit la pandémie
d'arrivée placée comme du lendemain
nouveaux maîtres de vince effet classé
comme beaucoup de
beaucoup d'ajustements puis
pyt la trentaine c'est comme si c'est
comme si la vingtaine c'est pas grave
comme enjeu comme jouets sont même si
comme c'est pas grave si
c'était pauvre le tpiy ce pas grave si
titre tu vois fonds du patrimoine
s'étaient pâtissent pas grave si tu
essaies des affaires puissent pas grave
si tu pars en voyage passe comme normal
c'est comme un tir mémoire david essayer
des affaires puis c'est comme le loto et
belote de quoi mais que tu sais
c'est pas grave on est arrivé au japon
dès la trentaine vient avec les espèces
de le supposer
point d'arriver quelque part on dit que
je ressens cette pression le tri comme
qu'il faut que quelques jeux bord de
piste en ville eux aussi d'avoir de quoi
de plus tard plus solide plus plus
normal si le temps était maître
travailleurs autonomes pour tenter à
fonte d'été comme
soient fins de semaines travaillées tout
le temps tout le temps tout le temps
tout le temple c'est comme ok mais si un
jour je vais les enfants je pourrais pas
faire ça c'est un jour je veux c'est si
un jour je vais jamais acheté une maison
il faut que je prenne des projets qui me
permette de pouvoir se cefac laisser
comme ça qu'il ya des affaires à
ski qui priorise m et tommy décision cet
été chez peugeot qu'est-ce qui me tente
plus de fabriquer ce qui va nourrir le
plus puis c'est encore ce qu'il faut que
ça reste dans mêmes efforts aussi comme
que ça fasse du sens dans comme dante à
son avis depuis quand donc aucun genre
des vitres avoir pu essayer d'équilibrer
ce puits
puis c'est drôle ce qu'était une grosse
réflexion par rapport à la normalité
puis on dirait que le plus que jamais
j'ai assumé à quel point ce comme ab il
y aura jamais cessé quoi aussi qu'est ce
qui est normal c'est une bonne question
il ya tout ce aussi tu manges et j'ai
réalisé à quel point j'ai une vie somme
toute mais tant que je compare à aux
membres de ma famille j'ai une vie
différente
mais quelle puissance que d'avoir des
membres de la famille qui font juste
accepter ce que c'est qu'en mai ben oui
c'est pas qu on t'encourage on va se
déplacer de voir le soir d'une faille
tout à l'éruption
mais ça a été quelque chose que j'ai
soudainement encore plus assumée de
faire comme eux ma vie va être un peu
différente mais normal pour toutes mes
amis c'est aussi c'est ce qu'ils
espèrent mais ce que j'entends dans ce
que tu dis donc c'est similaire à moi
c'est que j'ai des envies différentes
les nouvelles envies ouais genre
justement faire comme ailleurs oui j'ai
envie d'avoir week end of ouais j'ai
envie d envie d'avoir du temps pour
juste profiter c'est avoir une journée
tant de temps que je suis plus je sais
pas si pire regarder par la fenêtre
c'est dans la cave métier georges fr de
quoi de
moi j'ai découvert ce avec pitié si j'en
ai tout commence à faire du des courses
plus longues nous tu vas découvrir plein
de choses que j'ai découvert ces mets
ton me lever 1 dimanche j'ai fait ça
dans ma préparation pour le marathon de
saguenay j'ai fait ce cinq fois l'été
passé me lever un dimanche plus une
longue sortie fait que ces deux heures
et demie en montant prendre mon char
sortir de l'île de montréal allez dans
le coin soit tremblant ou de bromont
manif épi faire sopi c'est quoi ta
journée ma journée a été faire ce parce
que ça prend toute ma journée au complet
parce que temps de se déplacer tout sauf
qu'après ce jour venu chez nous c'est
comme
christ belle journée mais sait aussi que
pendant deux heures et demie mais même
s'il inclut le moment de route mettant
enfin deux rallyes nous en ressortons
mais un 6h30 août et post on téléphone
sans citer que ta musique ou outils
wever tu vas tu chaque état monde pour
ton temps mettez pas en train de
s'écrouler rien
c'est beaucoup de temps aussi à penser
puis à observer plein d'affaires c'est
tellement plus d'avoir le luxe mois ci
c'est est ce que quand je revenais chez
nous j'étais tellement reconnaissant
d'avoir eu le ce soit moi j'ai pas de
blonde je suis comme j'ai pas d'enfant
j'ai pas d'obligation puis s'être un peu
la vie que j'ai choisis vont maintenant
puis quand je revenais chez nous c'est
qu'une crèche dont maints genre the
bright fall je suis reconnaissant de
pouvoir avoir ce week-end tout changer
mais oui j'ai commencé à réaliser que je
faisais ça c'est niaiseux comment aussi
quand même
c'est comme n'importe quoi mais nommée
la reconnaissance c'est
fou comme 1
ça nourrit quelque chose mais je veux
essayer de dire plus à mes amis et
je lisais mots que j'y trouve beaux
outils puis c'est comme ça va jamais
nuire à une journée jamais le nommer
sortie moi je n'arrête pas de dire
hangzhou le moule life c'est quand je
vais life
live mais ça a commencé du jour puis
maintenant jeudi puis c'est comme gypse
en france pour ouvrir tuyaux c'est la
vie qu'on a choisi pour vrais pauvres et
et quelle chance c'est incroyable tu es
quand tu parcourir comme ceux est-ce que
commente nourris que matias aguayo
jamais nous a quittés des barges
rancourt des images déjà leur côté
féminin ben mosbah dégel que je vais
faire céder la poudre pour maintenant
ton ok mais c'est le même principe qui
peut soit prendre en liquide ou solide
donc il faut que je prépare parce que
sinon le ski tout ce qui est en haut
d'une réforme et on le stoppa de ses
soeurs et oriens s'étoffe de te sentiras
fin de tournée marathon c'est avait rien
actuelle ça a été papa j'étais super
chanceux mais si comme vous je ne savais
pas que j'allais courir à domicile fait
que moi je suis parti l'a fait bien
avant j'avais couru en 10 puis
je pensais pas être capable de courir
mais plus que ça dans ma tête c'était
journée l'heure quand je rentrais dans
le parc de la pointe taillon
c'était tellement beau j'avais dû être
secouru trois kilomètres le cheval pas
jamais secours un indice soit viré de
bord dans deux ans ce sera pas assez
long c'est vraiment un ace peut-être une
des premières faut aussi que je courais
puis que j'ai tripé beyrède le ty pas
que le cheikh mais je tombe je crois que
je me rappelle que quand on se parlait
de ça à ben ali n'était pas un coureur
le droff le seul à faire une halte ça
fait un an que je co j'ai commencé livre
a eu lieu exactement un an le plus ou
moins octobre l'année passée de quoi
même et j'ai commencé se passe mal je
courais des quatre kilomètres le
vraiment pas aussi vite juste pour dire
puisque non mais j'y ai pris goût de la
main kg comment ça courait aussi dans
des places qui sont belles ces cerises à
quel point c'est le fun un
fait que petit bateau remis par en bêta
5 6 kilomètres de chez nous fixons un
espèce de distance qui peut
rester relax
puis le peintre arguments pauvreté
augmente et puis c'est finalement quand
je courais au parc de la pointe taillon
je t'aime je tripais tellement que j'ai
fait à québec le jeu j'en ferais 7.5 ma
vie mais moi je veux faire un point le
rendu à 7.5 ça ne tentait pas de tourner
c'est ça la fin ça parfois j'y vais ce
le mien aussi j'ai pas été mieux parce
que je sais que j'ai de bonnes jambes je
m'entraîne beaucoup parce que j'étais
quand même que je vais pas me blesser je
les poivrons ma forme exacte que je
pense capable si je me sens super bien
ça veut c'est réaliste fait j'ai
continué fait que j'ai fait de 21 puis
j'ai eu les cuisses hérité c'est tout ça
c'est la vérité à cause des frottements
exact avait enlevé mon champ des faits
que je n'ai pas tué n'est pas
une blague c'est sa découpe des
matériaux qui sont qui font que réclamer
ton propre bâton pour eux
qui permettent de courir sentir it et ça
sauf que souvent c'est pas les matériaux
qui respirait plus le détail exact mois
ses jumelles et les tiges qui respire
beaucoup à ce que j'ai tendance à
vraiment
choqué glide ce n'est pas comme si des
eaux dans le fond c'est ce qui est
important même parce que ça peut être ça
m'arrivait mois les postes
à
répétition font ça m'est arrivé quand
même sur des fois des courtes distances
à dépenses vraiment du char dès que je
peux mais des fois ça m'est arrivé genre
sur indices us comme le lendemain au
monde du métal ou jetés au djing et puis
c'était dans une période que je faisais
classement du village dans ma prête pour
aller passer parce que l'année passée
j'étais au courant maintenant j'avais
déjà fait cette erreur là mais l'hôte
années d'avant puis je faisais vraiment
multiples mais n'est pas était déjà
évité et puis mon affaire 1,27 kg d
intervalle sur le tapis puis l'a6 sur le
tapis dans ses droits parce que c'est un
univers fait que jeter au jam qui plaît
je me mets à faire ce que je me raconte
de rêve parce que quand tu es dans le
moment - fait que je suis juste comme so
king ouest le dessus hors jeu
dégueulasse sauf que j'avais une
camisole bleus parle puis quand j'ai
fini je me suis regardé des coûts les
normes sont alors tournées j'ai croisé
le regard d'une fille qui assure les les
petits plats l'a fait à me regarder les
yeux pleins après ça la descente si ses
yeux perdus comme étaient horrifiés de
skype est voué à gt
dégueulasse mais après ça il a fallu
genre que je me mettre du tape les
autres fois d'après parce que j'étais
trop défoncé sur comment
ta préparation je suis un programme que
quelqu'un deux fils noah l année passée
dans le fond j'ai suivi un programme que
j'ai un panier sur internet d'un site
que ce qui donne un programme gratuit
pour faire un beau 3 ans au marathon qui
est là pour ma nouvelle peuple
j'ai une coach privé qui m'a fait un
programme selon mais tant pis vraiment
comme spécifiques à moi ça fait combien
de sortie six personnes ça va dépendre
pour l'instance pour beaucoup c'est
cattacin qui va-t-on mais éventuellement
ça va être des semaines je pense que le
programme avait des semaines qui monte à
120 kg
vert pendant 2 3 mois mettons la fin du
stock paris puis quand tu cours tu te
tue de la musique des podcasts aurait en
tout cas sur la vodka sauf quand c'est
des intervalles cassé désherbage mais
rien qu'en maintenant tu vas chercher la
vitesse le c sur la piste de jambes je
mets pas de musique ok il y est [ __ ]
de monde j'imagine saison j'ai pris ça
comme ça s'apprend ouais je sais ça
c'est la classe ces suspects ont celle
des enfants ouais ouais ça casse un peu
tu peux avoir une montre avec la musique
mais ce soir là se sait si je pensais
faire
c'est un sa griffe du tchèque parce que
se faire des ultras aussi tant qu'à
acheter une montre achète pour un jeune
qui capable de te fais le talent moi ma
montre harry potter de faire si j'avais
fini mon 80 kg à l'are manqué de
batteries avant à fond
c'est être y penser vraiment j'ai payé
comme un sale j'ai perdu connaissance
mais je vois leur faire faire plus que
oui ces métiers parlais tantôt le
d'aller courir dans des endroits qui
sont beaux le moins c'est cela c'est ça
la beauté d'ultra trail que manger du
crabe c'est comme tu comprenais pas le
monde qui me parlait du le trottoir
avant que je tombe de dames dont je vous
ai été malade est-il aujourd'hui tu vas
courir 20 heures de tentes et un full
puis le maintenant je comprends c'est
addictif mais on dirait que le demi a
débloqué quelque chose dans ma tête tout
ce que le ch comme j'ai fini cette
course le puis je savais sans aucun
doute dans mon esprit que je vais courir
un marathon un joint comme je suis
prochain d'apps marcheurs goût etc si je
mets s'acheter des meilleures choses
dans l'ouest des fois je courais dans
des dans la norme et merde et elle
demande une bague à wesley c'est une
scène pour aller courir dans ce trailer
mais c'est le single tracks même chose
que n'importe quel autre les locaux ray
lane en avant qui sont beaucoup plus
proches des forêts de l'est tellement
beau puis je suivais rien et il faut que
j'épouse checchi et j'avais il une des
nounous et tania m'avait donné une map
elle habite là-bas on m'avait donné une
map de village de whistler père m'avait
tout sur les issues et l'amérique était
à bali non non pas une terreur y avait
eu les vl non mais y avait une fille qui
faisait les wilayas jouit 13 à l'habiter
ah oui cela je me rappelle de ceux de
raison en tanzanie avec yes hockey ouais
elle avait dû travailler six autres
d'après n'ont cessé moi-même à bali
puisqu'à faisait les voyages je les
croisais il
faut que l'état nounou des candidats aux
maisons puis à m'avait tout montrer si
fait que j'avais finalement j'ai signé
une trêve que j'aimais particulièrement
qui était commun 13 km avec cette
défaite un peu plus âgé c'était super
puisse essayer des sorties à côté d'une
des maisons et des candidats j'ai le des
fois je parte à courir des maisons je
rentrais d'un trail de mountain bike
genre
il m'apprend sorties jeune star west le
jeu rendant d'entre elles j'avais une
heure régis couru comme 52 minutes je te
jure le feeling laissé à gérer plus
facile toute la journée des grands
bonheurs il ya des moments où tu montes
6-1 ait le site et même par un courant
mai mais
j'ai finalement compris c'était quoi le
monde me marathon j'ai flotté là dessus
la moitié de l'effectif même
des fois le mot ça m'est arrivé vraiment
fréquemment dernièrement le poignet le
rona et pendant que je coure le pis ça
faisait longtemps ça m'était pas arrivé
le plein de raisons mais là ça m'est
arrivé comme
5,6 fois dans le dernier deux mois
l'ouest jusqu'aux planeta du port
complètement le prêter tu es parti le
pitch du jeu revient juste quand
j'arrive dans ma rue mettons en jeu peu
après deux kilos je perds complètement
placé discrètement et a juste pu être lu
par tous depuis tu ramènes le site est
respectée et bien si tu as envie de
crier thème la vie ont complètement que
tu
réponds perret depuis pour la semaine
des biens après une bonne course dans
l'ouest un dimanche et je crois qu'il
est grand
les foules mais il je mange m'en
souviens c'était gris ce test est
nuageux mais il mouillait pas
et je sais pas pourquoi c'est super je
me suis mis juste du conflit
puis je suis parti pour 1 13 et j'ai
prononcé à
toulon mais fiction est venu me chercher
mais j'ai été payé il s'est passé de
quoi tout le reste est comme un malade
c'est c'est exactement les couleurs sont
plus crédibles c'est
vraiment moi je souhaite à tout le monde
d'expérimenter seul puis j'imagine ça
pousse à ce que ce soit dans d'autres
contextes que je te la course mais mais
mais aussi en fait c'est d'accepter que
on aurait parlé de tu ne serait-ce qu il
ya un an et demi j'ai fait ça me parle
vraiment les flamands trip là dessus
c'est ta pipe ses chandelles terme la
vie change la crypto bien tout ça
mais a lui aussi récemment le genre
d'aller courir si comme l'automne et sa
fille vers fait froid le soir benoît
après une grosse journée mettant c'est
quand elle mange à brûler de la journée
puis de partir il est comme pendant
vivre une expérience extrême ancien
havrais c'est ce qui c'est comme ça
sonne vraiment une scène sauf que
m'étant tarifs c'est fou comment ça fait
seul corps humain tu es fatigué tu vas
courir pendant une heure de plus
d'énergie comme des quintés renouveler
mais aussi toutes les espèces de ce test
était comme si tu accumules que la
journée comme le genre de kraft dans le
ventre comme l'écrasant vente tous les
vaincus les phoques dans le cerveau
espèce de
flou un portique avec quoi que le froid
puis le noir qui était comme vraiment
méditatif le ti comme que tu veux comme
rien que je rentrais jeter comme
complètement dans ma tête puis ailleurs
et compte vraiment c'est que c'est très
méditative comme un élément la
répétition la respiration exact un
complètement complètement juste à les
voires
je vais recommander à tout le monde puis
on espère vraiment le recevoir sur le
podcast prochainement mais mathieu
blanchard je suppose que c'est qui non
c'est un ultra
trail du tracteur qui est un français
mais qui habite à montréal y est arrivé
troisième aux structures du mont blanc
qui comme le super bowl d'ultra trail
mais c'est dans le fond c'est au tour du
mont blanc fait que tu fais tu fais
france tu fais suisse tu fais italie je
pense bête tu reviens tu reviens en
france je veux c'est vraiment
une course de trot pays avec un nenê ce
site dénivelé le fait vraiment c'est
vraiment gros stock les petits hisser en
haut des tabliers parce qu'il fait deux
degrés mais en bosses et les trafics 6
puis bref il ya fait un film lui parce
qu'il y est exposé t toute la saison de
l'autre autres elle a été cancellé à
cause de la cabine fait que lui il a
décidé de de faire ainsi 150 km dans le
parc national de la gaspésie fait que
c'est une truelle qui fait 650 ferment
qui arrivent jusqu'au bout de gaspé puis
il ya des six des farceurs pour essayer
de faire la f city le fast fast et non
face des montagnes avec cdc par le plus
vite possible sur l'enfant puis il fait
comment je pense six ou sept jours puis
il a fait un film qui s'appelle qu'on
finit qui te qui est probablement encore
disponibles à certaines places les
muscles à l'électro cinéma du musée ici
le c'est incroyable c'est incroyable des
fois le il des fois il fait gros soleil
c'est là la beauté des fois yvan type le
salon la salle à la absolument
incroyable plus y arriver à fond dans
les cinq derniers kilomètres
plus la caméra elle ferme puis diplôme
est plus capable j'en ris essuie les
larmes en courant puis j'ai reçu sur mon
podcast sébastien sasseville qui est un
jeu les connu
aux arènes de tremblant fait pour le
grand défi pierre lavoie j'étais
bénévole ou iron man puis mon ami pat
saint martin il ya travaillé dans le
temps québec avec sébastien sasseville
est diabétique
et à 22 ans hier ce sont diagnostiqués
diabétiques de
type 2 le plus je pense que j'oublie le
manga tu peux bon je les ai reçus ce
podcast où il dit visiblement j'ai pas
une je n'ai pas reçu d'informations et
en gros il sait pas dire tous les sports
dans ta vie est foutue slack là dessus
puis lui ça fait l'effet inverse enfin
que serait ton poignet le troisième
diabétiques avoir atteint le sommet du
de l'everest les facteurs 2008 après ça
s'est mis à faire marathon ultramarathon
et fait un ultramarathon dans le sahara
après ceux d iron man est en fait
plusieurs mais en 2014
il a traversé le canada la course
enfants et a complété la course de terry
fox
avec mon ami pat était le coordonnateur
de ce fait patte le suivait en zone
et on irait pas si c'est moi c'était de
quoi comme six ou sept marathons par
semaine puis il est parti mais je
couvrais que lucas et à montréal fakty
était pliée partie de l'est puis a
traversé vers l'ouest les deux pieds
dans l'eau d'un bar jusqu'à l'autre puis
il y avait tous ces malades puis le 28
voix cet été les dépasser donc en
juillet passé qui a traversé le canada
en vélo ait voulu faire le plus
rapidement possible puis vous l'arrivée
à la date d sentant de l'invention de
la peau la pénicilline
les limites les médicaments pour le
diabète
je pense que j'oublie que
j'ai fait la même erreur
et finalement cahier parti c'est la
journée où c'était qu'annick la canicule
total total total réforme intervient une
journée plus tard que prévu mais il le
fait en de quoi comme de rumeurs c'est
incroyable ça n'a aucun bon sens mais
c'est un christine pas de casque c'est
un lieu qui est vraiment vraiment
inspirant fort kent sweet fortune drôle
et puis ces genres de 10,3 qui était
comme
si justement ce que je pense que pour
les gens comme les autres j'ai
l'impression qu'on est affalée dans le
cerveau que quand tu entends du monde
parler comme ça quand mathieu blanchard
où il raconte des histoires étaient
jusqu à asti moi ça me craint que ce
montant est investi de mal à une mouche
comme j'ai envie de faire quelque chose
mais non mais même moi je suis sortie de
ce film le pis j'aurais
juste aller courir le ceser comme les
guides tu vas voir rapides et dangereux
pour la vitesse à
8h30 faisait moins certes puis-je aller
couvrir d'or le 12km proche de chez nous
là c'est sûr et comme c'est sûr que je
fais ça dans le fond et oui avec des
films du festival de films de benoît
baby a été choisi justement stosur
jeandupeux à pister seul c'est comme
c'est tellement le fun aussi pour ceux
pour voyager de sa manière
j'étais une semaine en australie en
nouvelle zélande ou s'il avait fait
sourire des mauges comme j'aimerais ça
me rendre le mail je veux j'ai pas
beaucoup de matchs via la course
j'allais voir telle plage quand tu as la
course c'est comme tu vois plein
d'affaires
c'est vraiment facile je trouve en
voyage aussi de garder la forme puis de
découvrir des choses sérieuses le besoin
ne pas de souliers d'enfants nus l'exact
contenu puis c'est parfait la nati sport
accessible pour que ce mouvement c'est
ce que comme joueur qu'ils n'ont je vois
qu'ils commencent à être dispendieux sa
trempe il le temps que tu pourras
congrès de la pop survenue n'était pas
besoin d'eux comme un geste jugé d'aller
nager dans la piscine trop besoin de t d
ça commence de plus le cinoche ce encore
wayne enfants dans mon programme j'ai 2
de natation par semaine dans l'autre
pour les premières semaines mais après
ça va enlever tranquillement ok pour
perdre de la masse un peu de du haut du
corps mais ouais parce que sinon c'est
trop dur sur les gens web c'est comme
une bonne façon moi je ne peux pas que
je pense qu'avant de faire
je peux regarder avant une journée off
dans ma vie en général l'autre jour
j'étais couché l'autre jour j'étais de
se jeter dans le bain genre je me suis
dit ok aujourd'hui fatigué je vais me
prendre une journée de repos j'ai pris
mon bail avec des oeufs l'essentiel des
chandelles j'ai lu un livre dans le bain
shirts ballons en avant dans mon livre
je continue à lire les livres plus je
regarde ma montre il se tord le fait
que je m'aime pas parce que je m'envoie
rappelé à chaque étape du moment je me
suis levé de mon lit mettre les souliers
à monsec même mon habit de jean prat mon
char à l'est jusqu'aux j'aime à chaque
étape de tout sujet de
leur rente au djembé mal j'ai fait une
heure et demie cette gym je revenais
chez nous en europe il ajouté comment le
chu bien exact je comprends tellement
cette semaine on vient de faire un
instit grosse session puis on t'a vu
trois jours de suez pcd on est poussé
fort les sept ans tu les as fin du 3ème
et comme demain demain du paf le sait et
prend ça
comme un enfant je peux tu faire des
enfants je peux courir
etc ah bah oui ce que tu veux
apprécier comme fait de la mobilité
c'est d'étudier ce fait seul petit tu es
toi j'ai un programme pour ce coup-ci
c'est simple rapide c'est maintenant que
tout commence à faire des vrais distance
le direct et du vrai millage maintenant
le rimmel faut que tu te fasses ta prêt
avant le tir la physio sais pas c'est
pas une faute tu t'es blessé le soin si
préventif le xplay combien de temps de
mobiles terre en partie un bon 20
minutes les jours à toutes les courses
maintenant ouais ouais peut-être une
différence quand même aussi mais l'art
est incroyable c'est un faux choix soins
voici nombreux blessés puis le 4 qu on
attend après combien de temps tu prends
des gels ou non mais dans sa série y est
mort ouais moi juste l'égard de notre
pauvre 45 km h à 40 45 ans je fais plus
qu'une me ouais y'a quoi dans ces gels
cd des glucides rapides ceux des kops
hockey ouais mais là je t'enverrai
woodstock ça ça va ça va tanguer le
jeune joueur
à faire j'ai pris j'ai testé puis j'ai
détesté l'enfant avant de le plus proche
que j'ai trouvé dessus c'était bpn de
nick bernois qui est qui qui
sait
[Applaudissements]
ce logiciel qui sont vides et holiday
homes ont induit en écho annuellement au
colorado puis gelé noter le chemin je
suppose j'aimerais ça a été a été le
dernier à rentrer avant le code of
il a été le dernier à rentrer avant
comme le temps de qualification il l'a
fait en vain tu t'approches 30
c sur le sapad estimant c'est ça la
malade les prises de vue c'est
incroyable la nuit les mots j'ai hâte de
faire ce juste pour courir la nuit legs
ma petite flash lite le comme essayer de
mort qu'est ce qui se passe là on
parlait avec un gage de manquer qu'il a
fait le plus marquant dre puis ils nous
disaient qu'il faut que tu qu aussi pour
le harricana celui que me s'inscrit 125
kg pour scorer avec un berges prix parce
que du commandant malbert ça se peut
qu'à ramener il ya une hausse en début
de la nuit à personne autour de toi il
n'ya pas de sécurité le titre sur la
suite on chemin et aptes à tomber ce
prêt pour
écoute pourtant si les autres dans
l'ouest
la première fois que tu as les cours et
d'un trail cas survenus j'ai dit ce haut
fait de prudence tout jamais que jusqu'à
marge et décorrélés c'est mal à quoi
s'est couru seul
tu avais rien à dire que
ma mère était moins kitsch
mais c'est l'effet de lol ouais c'est
bien
rodée mais c'est juste qu'on s'est fait
dire au début c'est bon c'est sûr mais
il ya des grizzlies labolt cissé dia
n'avait pas beaucoup dans le bourg de
whistler hittites tout ça c'est recensés
ils savent qu'il y avait une soixantaine
dos noir puis 3 grisy les grizzlies
habituellement sont ils viennent pas
dans le village ne se tiennent plus loin
les ours noirs c'est aux autres qu'on va
croiser un peu plus lourd
[Rires]
fardeau des animaux le genre tellement
badass qui en a juste trop on sait
combien ces noms mais gentil les
baleines bleues
50 on sait qu'à neuf secondes c'est rien
ça va commencer rien mais ton mais c'est
quand même pas au genre goryl on sait
qu'il ya dès que j'en ressens gorille
dans cette jeune danseuse ongles ces
facteurs on est allé et j'ai fait une
sortie un week end on est allé voir des
baleines à whistler là on avait pris la
route on est allé à kembo river sur
l'île de vancouver si je me trompe ou
lorsque et puis on fait une sortie le
guide était super fin c'était sa mère
est inquiète mme may a grandi dans
l'ouest et qui parle un peu français il
parlait bien français en fait super
gentil c'est comme un guide de journée
de même c'est comme la ligne est mince
entre y ait ce match qui donne
l'information piller loge vie y était
parfait le super cool y mouille et
faisait froid avait des one piece ferait
don sur des bateaux de 20 et on part sur
une demi heure qu'on est sur l'eau
baleines à bosse toute seule qu'elle sa
vie si je me trompe pas c'était elle ou
et les épaules à ces entre hawaii puis
vancouver se promenant
la pression continue plus loin et au
total la journée on a vu 22 et polar
comme on en a vu tellement comme on est
sympa on en a vu assis on va aller voir
autres comme on est blasé des épaules à
moyon qui pis est tellement coup
puisqu'il recense toutes là qu'ils
prennent des photos puis selon c'est
comme la leur tâche puis commission fait
ils peuvent finir par savoir quel groupe
c qui fait que pas souvent les bébés
reste avec la mère le père et quitte
puis il reste quand même en groupe puis
georges on a vu des baleines qui est
tanné des années 70 puis d'aubagne qui
avait trois heures mais qui connaissait
le sait qu'il doit ouais si demain tout
les bateaux se passe comment pas manquer
en élabore va les voir c'était tellement
impressionnant appelé parfois les
provinces et pour voir qu'on a vus comme
tes regards depuis ce même je peux pas
te décrire le décor on n'est nulle part
le tir en aide à de l'eau puis rien au
taux de 6 et des arbres puis y'a pas de
chalet c'est super beau puis hurle à
revisser ce genre sont le pitch
puissants comme hier il était jusqu à
moins que je suis prêt je voudrais que
j'arrêtais votre pensée c'est quoi la
revue a été commis ils sont juste leur
ensemble pitch il dit c'est fou le
président était très méditative de les
regarder aussi puis arrêté riad une demi
heure je n'ai pas droit d'être proche
des 200 m fait quand même puis après
c'est un peu plus tôt on a vu des
marsouins puis des dauphins qu'ils ont
sont venus jouer avec le bateau se on a
vu des déciles eyes peas eux c'était fou
raide le site est vraiment le comme une
hostie de journée avoir des animaux dans
leur état naturel
c'était tellement impressionnant ça
n'avait pas de bon sens c'est bon de
reconnecter avec la nature ce domaine
parce que ça fait surtout s'être fait
remettre en perspective justement mais
50 baleines bleues la région 50 le lésé
puisque 59 6 7 6 comment ces fragiles
commencent est important de oui sans
occuper d'helmand tellement puis il
était comme ça aussi c'est leur monde à
eux et ça leur appartient l'eau est
disponible un peu partout c'est la femme
s'est jetée jusqu'à mais parce qu'ils
savent pour les appelle les kilowatts et
comment la cia on n'est pas super sympa
comme ça ils savent ce
minimaux qui comprennent fucking truc le
célibat les ouvriers développe un genre
de langage à l'intérieur de chaque
groupe maintenant c'est fou je suis dit
on et d'attachement vraiment forts les
uns oui avec les autres leur exacte qui
d histoire justement de deux baleines
arrachés à leurs familles aujourd'hui on
va faire comme sur le tir ce système en
crise car parce que gens savent ils
sable ici je connais depuis vingt ans
plus tard dû servir et puis se
reconnaîtra est
[Musique]
ce pour ça c'est juste dans les sites
web que le roi leur truc arrondi oui on
se tire pas toutes mes mots je sais rien
n'y fit
picasso
qui sont encore verts
oui qu'ils aient dit que
l'info qui donne la bostonnais mettons
les épaules en espérance de vie d'amour
et rentrent en jeu puis en can ah parce
qu'après 30 ans à séoul créé en mai que
dans dans l'océan cédant 4 avril
on en a vu qui était né en 70 ans de
coma
c'était à la fin de la crise je me
rappelle du documentaire c'est tous des
anciens qui ont traversé world qui
partager l'information que c'était
normal que l'aileron courbe plafond is
amène dans le wild pour voir des débats
complet puis avec des ailerons fois king
le tout la gagne qui ont témoigné jean
pendant le film il se met à pleurer ou
ce qu'ils disent tout toutes ces années
longtemps on disait que c'est normal on
on expliquer que c'est comme ça que
c'est avec ses dix elles évoluent et
finalement qu'un qui sont dans nature
sont toutes ensemble que les ailerons
main droite oui ces fous pareils imagine
ton aileron est ici les jeunes sont à
vendre au
lycée courbet
[Musique]
mais c'est aussi
pendant des documentaires mari engagé
que c'est comme au japon comme une
espèce de wii
comme une espèce de deux places qui
amène les doigts de plage le ticket de
bio exact parce que j'en ris avec comme
une technique jean d'ultrasons jory film
entre dauphins le plafond juste comme
les limaces les ops et cdc des animaux
justement tellement
genre
bon le team naïf un peu plus gentil
temps marc levin de woippy le joyau là
tout gentil on disait que c'est quand
même triste parce qu'on dirait que c'est
ils se rendent pas compte à quel point
on dort on dirait que
il nous donne crissement après d'amour
mais tant qu'on leur donne pigeât qui
seront pas comptés comme les autres il
est de nouveau tout émerveillé genre
petit gentil pis ils savent pas comment
mal on les traite le film où là c'est
spécial aussi parce que quand tu vois si
tu fait de ton
c'est là que tu vois quel point mon dieu
que les êtres humains on est vraiment
différent c'est comme tout le monde
il ya des affaires que nous on adore que
d'autres détestent sur la musique
d'abord craint pas et vice versa il ya
des gens qui sont capables de faire ce
qu'ils apprécient peut-être carnet qui
n'ont pas le choix pour faire vivre leur
famille dit j'estime que mon post ici
comme
c'est assez évident qu'on devrait pas
faire seul tir en tant que groupe
puis finalement c'est comment ça se fait
et pc mais ces seuils ne dépassa murray
je pense souvent dans ce genre d'affairé
je penserai qu'à donner bélanger d été
et 6 milliards et de celui de solitude
c'est vrai on est vraiment tout seul on
sait tout on saura jamais c'est quoi
vivre la vie de quelqu'un d'autre ces
factures mais ton corps et des longues
distances physiquement tu es capable
même siv en europe il ya des gens qui
est pour eux c'est littéralement
impossible physiquement de faire ce
qu'il y en a pour qui chris le banc
d'arracher sa mère faire la docksides
outils comme si tellement facile
c'est vrai
a littéralement salut c'est titi fait
comme maman gauthier on est vraiment nos
shit aussi que le monde est si compliqué
on est tellement vendu beaucoup que
j'avais entendu qu'est parc dès que tu
étais plus que 550 le ça commence à être
compliquée âgées dans ses pièces
et ceux qui comme jusqu'à 150 team et on
les regarde mais dont l'organisation
d'un groupe qui se fait relativement
bien putté pas décemment besoin d'avoir
une hiérarchie claire d'abord des rôles
tu leur pic est passé
mais de passer sur deux ça devient
complexe mais c'est tout neuf a aussi
mais ça me fascine le leadership de le
regarder se tait quand tu es ne serait
ce qu'une équipe un gros job
devoir commun dans un j'ai déjà eu des
conversations avec des classes des
étudiants des finissants billets et ça
prend le 3 minutes ok le leader dans la
classe on sent que l'énergie est l'idée
par cette personne là où ces personnes
là où ce groupe le 6 e groupe l'un
des leaders positif s'influencent
vraiment le reste du groupe et si les
leaders sont négatifs c'est un vrai jeu
j'observe à od j'absorbe d'emprunt de
place je sais comme c'est fascinant le
leadership est faible ça c'est fou comme
1 et moi le premier je peux vraiment
c'est le groupe atteint il ya un leader
qui est l'up finalement ça nous direct
de danton sais pas trop pourquoi puis on
se laisse aller mais on a besoin de lits
deux très très très puissant et très
positif parce que mais on est rendu
tellement beaucoup c'est justement quand
une société
huit millions six cents supporteurs on a
des vies tellement différente et les
géographies mans c'est différent les
réalités sont différentes mais qui est
restée je prenne une décision pour tout
ce monde là qui ont toutes des intérêts
complètement différente des désirs et
des envies puis début quand le messie
qui en bout de ligne à manier comme dans
les organisations de se faire lui arrive
les absurdités comme étant le diable la
fin des dauphins ou la sphère de que les
briquets l'injustice me paraît quelque
chose qui te dit ça a pas de sens qu'on
fasse c'est comme un dj allemand luz
mais les grands majorité on est bons
puis bien intentionnés je pense le cpie
aux gens ce matin en disant j'ai envie
de tuer des dauphins sauf que le dans
l'organisation des trucs c'est comme les
c'est comme si le système devient le
plus gros coup dur inclus mais il ya il
se crée des espèces de débats lancement
puisque rideau en fer que la ministre
est bâti fès a pas de distance que ça se
passe demandent si comme cela comme un
peu de la faute à personne ses combats
et ses moyens physiques comme ceux qui
c'est comme ça que c'est beaucoup
déresponsabilisation 6 puis c'est moi le
premier des affaires que je m'accorde
pour le clic sur la samare de même puis
je me pose pas trop de questions on sait
pas de mon ressort où ça marche comme
cet épi mais c'est là où des fois
je trouve que encore une fois sur ses
revient au leadership beaucoup de ces
si les leaders se déresponsabilise le
reste du groupe en dessous c'est
souvent ça prend beaucoup de courage
aussi le tir en version leader août
c'est comme cette époque ne serait-ce
que juste d'une classe je peux si vous
aviez été dans une classe où caroline
l'ambiance et étoffes et ça prend du
courage en ciblant le faire comme nolan
on le sait ça marche pas et puis non ce
jeu trop juste dire à quelqu'un et non
c'est jack ne la trouve pas drôle
mettons le
jt d'une jeanne d'arc et où un joke
proches il était dit que je suis un des
seuls de paris puis finalement c'est
quand mais j'étais adulte maintenant on
fait c'était vraiment un peu et puis la
personne n'a subi que j'avais pas
compris
j'ai fait ce que j'ai dit cachet
d'antan spectacle oui j'ai pas dit aux
gars je sais j'ai compris
mais
je trouve que servir beaucoup à cette cg
c'est deux jours par contre prendre
responsabilités ces
affaires là je te demande si on en parle
de plus en plus juste comme intervenant
qui inquiète quad qui se dit qu'il soit
un commentaire raciste ou misogyne outil
performant même pis on les entend même
temps c'est quand même cru c'est quand
même top de mettre ton pied à terre dans
un souper de famille pour dire à ton mot
non de fermer sa gueule puis de pas
faire ce genre de joe klaus pas mal
facile de j'espère comme
mais après ça même des fois c'est
d'essayer de le faire de manière
justement
douce ou bienveillante puis même si
c'est que ça demande beaucoup de
patience beaucoup de force
fait que
même si ce que j'aime le plus c'est ce
que j'admire le plus du moins des
personnes qui sont capables de te dis ça
mais faut que tu dises ça me tombe c'est
comme
je l'avais pas
ce qu'ils
savent faire en culpabilisant ou en
schématisant on fait tous des erreurs
qu'on apprend tout de même une série
culte ouais
c'était
comment est ce que ton
ton expérience parce qu'à chaque cas à
chaque année on s'en reparle commence
que mon expérience d'auteur était
différent des autres mais qu'est ce que
t'as ressort puis qu'est-ce qui est ton
caisse qui t'ont plan pour après je suis
arrivé qu'un superbe au moins deux sites
cette année je pense que la pandémie ou
city ça a été dur pour beaucoup
d'artistes et beaucoup des dettes et des
restaurateurs du monde de tous les
milieux mais c'est seul
moi j'ai des collègues littéralement qui
on trouvait des jobs c'est cela la
réalité puisque les jobs standard way
tournée trail en construction ou enfin
ma part c'était comme à faire c'est
arrivé du monde titre comme qui
travaillaient qui gagnent très bien leur
vie avec le monde
notons milieu aussi
magnifique sac on dirait que plus que
jamais j'ai
juste et reconnaissant de travail et je
réalise la chance que j'avais d'avoir
une geek comme ceux en plus l'on revive
est rodé à l'extérieur du québec vaincu
aussi c'était une chance de hey je veux
voyager je vais habiter pendant trois
mois à l'extérieur de ma province du
moins là
qu'on serait jeté près je n'arrivais
très très très conscients de cette
chance là
et je me suis mis d'amendé c'est tout si
ou ce que je l'est puis je pense
qu'après si c'est ça aussi l'expérience
dans la vie tout comme tata tata taxus
différemment mais londres est que je
pense pas que je n'ai jamais tenu pour
acquis cette double mais le plus que
jamais je la tenais crissement pas pour
acquis chez comme jeu je voulais tout
prendre ce que cette règle avait à
offrir puis être tout aussi généreux
envers elle est rejetée comme genre beau
rôle mais dans cette jungle si j'ai un
rôle qui est super le fun parce que je
voulais être plus généreux avec mon
équipe plus généreux avec tout le monde
c'est de mon énergie de ma bonne humeur
de mes blagues dit oui ce soit
volontaire je m'étais mis le mot je t'ai
avant de partir j'avais écrit sur le
papier comme c'est justement régime et
un constat chanceux je suis reconnu soit
volontaire fait j'en venais souvent
j'avais comme lens et semer leurs
emplettes sauf physiquement le tout
leurs écrits j'avais écrit un peu pour
me donner une espèce de direction de
cette saison le la saison passée ça a
été plus difficile
moralement ça va être plus tendu c'était
plus c'était pas je fais pitié pas tout
blanc tout pas tout même s'il y avait
une coupe des petites affaires des
situations plus inconfortable plus tendu
dans l'aventuré qui fait que ça a détoné
sur tout le monde dans l'aventuré en
doute il ya eu les ailes québec à ce
moment là aussi c'était pendant la
saison daudet j'avais porté un long
débardeur un genre de robe ça avait fait
jaser et avait une coupe de petites
situations il y avait une coupe de
situation dans la saison aussi qu'
arrêter rien de dramatique évidemment
mais des justes et des trucs qui m'ont
fait attention que s'accumulent wipikit
m'ont fait me poser plein de questions
puis en fait que ben j'ai pris l'hiver
passé plus un prof pour revoir ce qu'est
ce que qu'est ce que j'aime dans qu'est
ce que j'aime pas qu'est ce que je veux
prendre qu est ce que je veux laisser
juste poussé ma réflexion un peu plus
bien précis je pense aussi que c'est un
contexte comme tout artiste est la copie
de piste et c'était plus compliqué pour
tout le monde je pense à gaz dans tous
les milieux au site et enfin que cette
année est arrivé vraiment connaissance
de cause de comme agir signé je sait
dans quoi je m'embarque sa cinquième je
le fais mais volontaire chance une
reconnaissance et l eamau l'acheter
quand on fait se dit oui moi car madame
ans j'ai su vers la question c'est
souvent pourquoi j'ai beaucoup besoin de
comprendre dans le village pourquoi mais
ta manif comme elle est un ouvrier dans
l'équation enlève le pourquoi du jeu
souidi oui puis en plus l'âge et
l'expérience de faire même s'il ya des
moments où soit le pourquoi outils des
fois quand chez nerveux je deviens plus
fermé maintenant j'ai réussi c'est comme
le pourquoi vie un peu comme acheter du
temps c'est comme dit oui j'ai été
capable est capable de faire ce qu'il
faut que j'oublie ce espagne et zulte
que tous que ce n'est plus les décisions
mettront de la prod se savoir pas
nécessairement les grosses décisions
mais des fois c'est je sais j'y ferai
quand on se met dès que c'est pas prévu
je réalisais que puis après s'il ya
beaucoup d'imprévus que ce manque que
c'est ce fait comme année c'est comme
besoin de savoir si six ans avant ce
métier la veille james avons une idée de
ce que je donne le lendemain mais des
fois crime construisent tout change
puisse écouter auditeurs de l'émission
qui sont vacants sur indices insee la
prestation 6 passes de quoi si
finalement je quitte le soir puis qu'il
se passe de quoi des maisons mais ça
fait que le lendemain évidemment ça
marche pas non madame bro c'est trop on
avait prévu une activité un peu rentrer
dedans que les candidats on va on va se
monter c'est finalement aujourd'hui août
à la fin fac et finalement
j'ai vraiment fait comme kiva dit oui
puis rappelle toi qui étais capable de
faire ce temps fils de joe belote est
capable de faire
ça vient déjà de me préparer pour ce
projet réalisé weekes et ce dès fois
j'oublie que j'ai aussi je suis
quelqu'un qui peut justement toute assez
instinctif je post super
méthodique dans ma manière de faire les
choses si ça va facture même si je le
cède à vence je pense qu'un défaut
j'étais plus nerveuse en afrique du sud
j'avais reçues du 6 pages et d'une
journaliste qui travaillait avec nelson
mandela son mari c'est jay naidoo qui a
travaillé qu'elle s'était irrité
chercher nelson mandela la sortie de
prison c'est comme puis je me souviens
d'en vendre en retourne à l'hôtel le
soir et 9h 9h30 you demain à midi et
deux passes lucie pagé en entrevue
me suis préparé les jeter comme pauvres
et on est loin de demander à quelqu'un
c'est qu'ils sont connes miroir sur le
corps à corps avec pertinence et
sélectif hacker se connaître j'étais
super nerveux le lendemain matin je m'en
suis tellement parce que je t'ai je
pense que quelqu'un d'assez smat d'envy
le jeter un peu comme les sources france
n'allait rien qui me tentait pas on veut
tourner si j'imagine d'un café face à
face non non on va être simple à lyon ca
plage de quoi tu parles sa plage puis
finalement mais on a trouvé un spot où
on était assis à côté de l'autre c'était
super cute on n'était pas par terre on
était la plage et être derrière nous
puis dès que j'étais super nerveux
facteur.com pas être mais un patient
puis finalement l'uci est arrivé puis
c'est quelqu'un de vraiment vraiment
boblbee on parle beaucoup du spa j'ai
vraiment généreuse vraiment fine son
mari s'appelle jeff hackett arrivé comme
moi j'aime seul et jean cap jallet vu et
tout de suite j'ai pensé était bien
content d'avoir stress à narrosse très
sainement enfin l'euro près de riga
toile soit comme toute l'histoire
d'afrique du sud au complet non c'est ce
que j'ai apprécié et immense et comme
j'ai pas faire semblant de savoir tout
ce que je peux y poser les questions non
si c'est exact pas grave c'est que
finalement ça a été une super rencontre
ç'a super bien été mais après j'ai dit à
mon équipe et je suis désolé séchage
j'étais nerveux c'est ce que je dirai
que ça me fait remarquer parce que
maintenant elle observe mieux quand je
suis là je deviens patients quelque
chose comme je sais que je n'ai revu que
je fais plus attention c'est enfin que
fax d'années on dirait que je t'ai comme
très conscient de tout ce fait que ça a
été tellement le fun c'est une saison
tellement tellement le fun on est rodé
aussi l'équipe ensemble c'est en fait à
chaque saison s'améliore non seulement
dans la manière de faire les choses mais
aussi dans l'organisation dans la
communication enfin que ça a vraiment
été plaisant
on est super bien oui ce litige était
très très très très bien
ça a été vraiment vraiment vraiment le
fun puis ça a été une saison su ce que
je me suis détaché un peu plus tg rien
écouté l'année passée c'est au québec
fecq je limite un peu plus
mes parents je commets pas vous empêcher
d'écouter bbb voyons là j'ai réalisé à
quel point ça ça met pendant le
processus pour moi ça met pas ses fins
fac cette année j'ai littéralement rien
écouté puis évidemment au courant de
tout ce qui se passe puis ç'a vraiment
vraiment été lu le fun c'est ça a été
tellement tellement plaisant puis puis
c'est 6 pour ceux ci tente on parlait de
nour et la reconnaissance en été vous
avez jeté comme à ça je sais tu es bon
comme on dit c'est fait compter que j'ai
appris c'est à quel point mais il ya une
préparation aussi à mon départ du 10 km
choses aient quitté
encore une fois fort chanceux puis on
fait rosiers mais c'est quelque chose
dit des fois que ça a été ça a été
intense mais je me trouve chanceux de
pouvoir leur faire je me trouve chanceux
qu'on me le demande on était pour elle
après cinq ans passés que ces exemples
on veut changer pin ce serait normal ils
m'ont aussi tiges et vous a même tout
même toi je rappelle qu'on avait une
discussion a mené même pas même pas cela
l'autre d'avant chez nous des gens
disaient je sais pas si je vais leur
faire je sais pas ça me tente première
map je sais pas si mon malheur gros free
roam sp4 des jeux dans un
set comme
l'an dernier quand il faisait ouais je
suis parti avec seulement une set le en
faisant
la même temps à chaque saison je me
disais c'est le plus que jamais c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles je pense
moment 17 était aussi bon c'est comme
prend tout parce que le jeu pensé mais
ton à la journée je veux dire à tout le
monde
c'était ma dernière au piège du panier
le motton ne tient que parce que hermann
et ça va ça va être décoré mais tu vois
quand on me l'a offert j'ai réalisé que
j'ai pissé là où la réflexion par
rapport aux 10 demeure tout le talent
présente parce que ça reste une
téléréalité de détecter mai c'est du
divertissement puis c'est correct mais
je pense aussi que ben moi mon apport à
ce je le sens je le vois ce que moi
j'amène à ce projet le 10 mai après six
ans d'attenté souvent les je peux sans
vous êtes jeudi ce métier quand quand
offre une guide la règle des 3 pt le
plaisir les personnes puis la paix est
souvent mais quand tu peux avoir les 3
c'est super et puis des fois mais moi ça
m'est arrivé de dire oui à des geeks
juste parce que je veux travailler avec
telle personne n'était pas payant ce
sera pas nécessairement le fun mais je
veux travailler avec telle personne puis
je les fais plus rapide des fois mais
c'est juste la paix c'est déjà arrivé et
puis des fois c'est juste ça s'arrête le
fun c'est sûr je le fais un peu importe
le reste mais à rodez j'ai vraiment les
3 way m'apprécient c'est juste que
l'espèce de street cred guillemets
outils ce que les gens pensent de moi
fait partie aussi quand même de ma job
mais le team hm c'est quand même moins
là tout ce port de moi c'est ce qui est
un peu bizarre sexton jobs public mais
le team ans et ça c'est pour moi c'est
que je le fais aussi fait que c'est
juste de pub un carmelo fin j'étais
comme je prends toujours ma décision en
revenant lui qu'en tant que je revienne
je le sais pas puis le match qui comme
elle s'est vraiment il ya des trucs ou
city ce qu'on voit sur le web des fois
ça va être le poteau que le négatif mais
c'est là qu'on va le voir plus
mais ce que je sais que j'essaie de me
rappeler le plus souvent
c'est les gens qui me disent qu'ils
réunissent pour écouter sochaux le we
puis c'est une grosse partie aussi
d'audit et des familles qui comptent
ensemble d hadopi des parents qui se
parlent ensemble moi quand même fait
avoir des conversations qu'on n'aurait
pas aux censeurs ou de mousse chez nous
je faisais des invités des amis on s'est
inscrits pays pointés au début mais
c'est ça ça m'a fait très mal et il ya
des lieux où gisèle ça va être un gros
show dimanche prochain préparez vous une
fondue la gagne pas ça va y aller mais
se fait à cause de la fonte grise est
d'accord brut et fait qu'il ya quand
même quelque chose
des fois j'essaie de penser à quand je
revois 75 ans comment je veux looking
back
puis comment s quand même un classique
qu'est baudet j'ai la chance d'avoir
deux pieds dedans ce moment piste à nous
autres mois le feeling à odyssée qui est
pas d'adultes qui nous surveillent seul
feeling c'est qu'on est une gamme de
gens ont tellement sont tellement
travaillant puis généreux pis ils se
donnent tellement la peine son équipe
qui est tellement tellement j'ai jamais
vu ça des gens aussi fin drôle le fun
est aussi compétent non attendue et
compétences et il y en ad'autres prod
télé le qu'ils sont pareils mois ci
c'est qu'est-ce que ça dégoûte et ça
paraît que c'est une gang de jeunes
passionnés c'est s'est pas fait abbott
je voulais une crise non risque annoncé
ça paraît que c'est fait pas du monde
qui veulent faire le meilleur show
possible du monde qui en donne plus long
plus que l'or et puis le lendemain de
mon frère qui travaille en cinéma fait
que très peu de monde dans ce milieu
puis il connaît bien 2d comme douze
moteurs ses coûts de ses amis qui sont
montés sur des cpie des machines de
guerre des machines de guerre petit
million d'iphones qui prennent les
marges pis le yi he said des affaires
fait des effets là il y en a qui
apparaît dans ce dossier
randy
jsk s'appelle que
quitte ma mère mon frère des fois je
fais des enfants puis je suis ce qu'au
stade d'après vont me dire que tu peux
pas faire ça ça n'a pas de sens à sa
portée le temps on a la liberté déjà en
fait des niaiseries jane pitt il le
montage est tellement créative d'être
tellement drôle opposé des affaires la
musique qu'ils maîtrisaient pas qu'ils
font c'est comme ça c'est fait avec car
sa part été dit que je dois dire oui
c'est juste un job dating dans le sens
et comme
c'est comme des pays traditionnellement
aussi odetti mettons les saisons de ça
avec comme une espèce de deux un côté
qui était tag quétaine douchebag c'était
très associé à ceux de
ces abrutis qui font selon présence d'un
king le silence pour écouter oui
exactement
sauf que maintenant que quoi de vraiment
y
assumer belgique dans si je te jure
indique shops en rêvant pas la roue qu'
il ya tout une job valeur ajoutée
georgas de
dix ares très mainstream petit genre
cipolla qui valait plus grande réflexion
philosophique sur la société pseu mais
pour bien du monde
parce que ça touche tout le monde
presque tout le monde vraiment beaucoup
de monde qu'ils aillent des pigments sur
la culture autochtone qui avait des
petites affaires comme ceux pour ben du
monde c'est des fois un premier pôle est
un peu
le test event business le fait qu'il
emporte que ça peut représenter pour
certaines personnes ben oui c'est
gigantesque loti d'avoir un steven à
rodez même les gens qui connaissent pas
vraiment vraiment spéciale si on est
chanceux qui sont inscrits à haut débit
afin qu'ils puissent importante dans la
représentativité est important plus
haute est aussi je pense qu'une des
raisons pour lesquelles ça fonctionne
aussi c'est que les gens peuvent se
disant moi comment je serai là dedans il
faut que
metz et se fait que je pense que ça
j'ai beaucoup celui mon feeling car
moeller et au fait j'ai fait hec encore
heureux de faire si ça semble encore
faire du 106e joissains j'ai
l'impression que la journée ou joueur
fait le tour pour vrai je vais le sentir
aussi aux règles faut que je fasse
confiance à mon instinct
est encore dit si tu y mettons la voyons
un fétu biais de saison mes tantes et
puis amman et 7,8 c'est comme
on sentait qu'on avait fait le tour le
team et on mon ex l'avait fait la
troisième saison
basse et se dire oui le concept
s'essouffle à manier les candidats
s'essouffle vite on sent que c'est
l'ordre la page
à mon avis aux textes encore
wtcc 6 pi 6 po ge à l'eau à appuyer une
voix à porter ça c'est encore la vente
est encore trop court si
ce gars a dit puissants que les piles de
plus grand des fanboy mais pour moi
c'est y est bon pour moi il est quelque
chose de droit et de mire les veines
dans ce show l'appui de d'importants
kezman j'ai faim je me pose plein de
questions puis je pense que je serai
jamais que justice que dans ma vie ça
m'amène apprécie ce que sa mère en vie
déjà je ne saurai jamais tout à fait au
complet
et si je pense que tu peut l'observer de
mille manières au dtp toutes ces manuels
sont ben correct 7,6 tant que ça fait du
bien ou que ça ne serait ce que pendant
un instant tu rigoles tu pense à rien je
pense que c'est correct
mais apprécier quelque chose d'aussi de
2,13 intéressant à observer des fois tu
aimais des situations où je veux
observer ses piges comme un mois je
serai comment là dedans et puis le
contexte du ct le contexte spécial en
crise c'est vraiment avec moi à cela
qu'il
faut quand même que je me rappelle que
je les fais tu dans la 2ème de pointe et
puis le saviez de me rappeler que j'ai
faite parce que sinon vous écouter
parler puis je pensais pas du tout à mon
expérience c'est spécial c'est que
j'observe toujours cette année où j'ai
un rôle assez space parce que selon où
je suis comme le issime un jeu avec vous
autres matches le représentant de la
prod qui leurs représentants des
candidats
mais après c'est sûr d'en haut des
tissus au souper d'élimination je peux
être représentant de la prod by du
public sur un haut plateau je prête à
conjuguer différents chapeaux j'essaie
beaucoup de
jeu posé protéger les candidats c'est au
printemps ce parce que j'ai peur j'ai
jugé possible
aux puissances leur attention mais
surtout que je ne suis pas choisi pas
grand chose c'est juste que je sais que
je peux un peu en accompagner certains
plus que d'autres selon jusqu'où ils
seront dans l'aventuré puis se rendre
loin plus j'ai de la proximité avec le
plus je peux leur parler tu me brasser
la fois que je trouve taux fixe je sais
que c'est un show qui est très facile à
pointer du doigt puis si je le comprends
c'est correct les gens ont le droit à
leur opinion c'est beau citant ceux ci
plus le défaut le manque de respect qui
va venir avec certaines à foix où
certaines histoires que les cheveux
comme
homère déjà je trouve ça des fois c'est
une raison aussi pour lesquels moi je
puisse moi je m'éloigne du des réseaux
sociaux à cause de ça aussi ça finit par
être comme aux attentes et un grand
manque d'humanité le monde oublie
complètement que quelques uns le pic est
une émission puis la montagne est
quelqu'un qui fait quelque chose avec
lequel dépend la grâce d'une émission
belle aussi comme c'est la personne
depuis envoyé 10 le type soc à maputo
cinq romans d'introspection sais pas ce
que je fais comment j'en ai fait des
gaffes danville et crispy demande le jeu
devant nos vitrines caméra pour un
montage comme le love leurs pires
moments c'est sûrement les longs moments
les plus éco et
rapidement des voix lui puis moi je
pense que c'est ce qui des fois les on
va pas nécessairement observés mais que
moi de mon et de mon rôle espèce de
vision que j'ai assume toute assez
unique de steve cholet sait que
j'observe à quel point il ya des
personnes qui peuvent
apprendre beaucoup d'été on a rarement
l'occasion de s'observer comme ça pour
ne pas dire jamais ça peut être super
inconfortable évidemment mais ça peut
tellement une grande sans fin qui
facturent ce quand même intéressante
c'est niaiseux mes moutons dans
dernières années j'ai réalisé que
j'étais impatient c'est quand même
violent pour réalise
jamais trop vieux mais ça a été un
espèce d arrêt met your mother le car il
ya le bruit de la ville qui pèsera pas
sur mon chien qui fait ça mais ça a été
ça par rapport à moi de campoli shit je
suis impatient
en faisant au dictionnaire autre nom
dans ma vie tu es à moi mais ces gens-là
farouche au chaos dit tu peux observer
des enfants comme ceux du candidat du
moins encore plus que que moi même aussi
un peu par la bande puis tout le monde
si je pense que messi se fait que je
leur fais puisque j'ai réalisé aussi en
fait c'est que
j'ai envie que ce que je ressors de
cette saison le plus apprécié aussi ses
passes pandémie pas finie maîtrise du
moins au point où on en est dans
pandémie j'observe à quel point jusqu'à
manquer mais qu'est ce que je fais du
reste de mon année c'est sûr maintenant
que sur lequel je vais me concentrer
parce que neuf mois pour l'exactitude ça
peut prendre beaucoup de place bien
évidemment que dans le teen king
populaire chasse au sjao die for ever ça
me veut c'est cru que c'est vraiment
correct puis que les gens sachent pas
que je fais quelques je suis humoriste
wever ça me dérange plus maintenant
parce que je sais qu'il ya des gens qui
le savent qu'ils vont me suivre pour
ceux qui vont acheter des billets peut
sauver mais parfaite mais les gens ça
prend seulement que c'est sur mon
premier métier parce qu'est ce qui t'a
premier métier qu'est ce qu'il en est
c'est tout ça au début c'est quelque
chose qui m'inquiétait beaucoup la
première saison j'étais présenté comme
l'humoriste dit dans le super important
pour lui maintenant je suis comme tout
ça c'est bien beaucoup calmé en moitié
c'est plus moi par rapport à moi c'est
en tout cas parler de la trentaine x cse
aussi soudan vingtaine j'avais beaucoup
à prouver aux autres j'ai l'impression
puis le réalise que ou même à moi même
des fois de me prouver que je suis
capable de faire ça moi oui moi je peux
faire c'est une blonde rect ça s'est
beaucoup calmé je peux je devrais être
moins en représentation même si c'est
une job qu'il est beaucoup j'ai essayé
d'être le plus sincère possible le plus
comme moi c'est ce que j'ai envie de
faire rts qui est ce que aussi parce que
je me rappelle ces conversations mais on
les avait eu déjà qu un quinté au début
le camp du posé cette question justement
est ce que je veux vraiment faire au
départ ce que parce que je veux être un
humoriste et je veux je veux que ce soit
être respecté par mes pairs dans
l'humour le tir est-ce que six cases le
sait quelque chose qui qui sont un peu
des truites avec le temps dans ta tête -
dans ma tête oui après si j'essaie de
donner moins d'importance à ce que les
gens pensent de moi plus d'importance à
ce que les gens que j'aime vraiment
pensé à moi c'est si ma mère trouve que
je peux bien mauvais mauvais mauvais
scoop je devrais avoir là l'intelligence
de l'écouter ou du moins de me pose la
question mais milieu de l'humour mais
tant le milieu du mot c'était moi j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration pour les
humoristes et j'aime ces gens là j'ai
respecté
j'essaie d'apprendre de la plupart de
deux autres eux aussi ça fait longtemps
que j'ai débuté
ça fait un moment que je peux dans les
bars je m'étais et le progrès en place
tout en un où je me sens aussi bien
qu'aux bordel tu es trop de bordel puis
c'est quand même un oui mais oui est-il
pi3 nive dans leur mine winnie mais nous
avons mis un billet jusqu'à sauf que ça
aussi ça s'est calmé au départ c'était
une peur du jugement puis comprenez je
pense que là aussi tout le monde c'est
tout c'est assez je pense qu'avec le
temps au site et les époques changent
vite quand même je vais pas dire des
époques mars que les tanks king change
vite je pense que l'essai de beaucoup
plus libre
y'a plus il ya moins se
cache pas les codes du monde si je suis
rentrée 2011 pipe
il y avait il y avait une vague de
comédiens maton qui voulait faire une
vague avec quelques comédiens qui
voulaient faire des one man show puis
des fois il y avait des puristes mais
oui on en a perçu c'est quand même tout
seul maintenant j'ai l'impression que
c'est plus parce que au final c'est bon
c'est pas bon mais c'est celle ci qui
m'amène la seule affaire qui fait que je
traîne maurice professionnel c'est que
les gens achètent des billets c'est
comme que j'ai est telle que de l'humour
ou pocket les excédents dans l'oeil de
celui qui consomme c'est que tu le fais
tu sais comme fin tout ceci
un sort jeté un chat en direct de
l'univers je parlais que biz backstage
jeu mais je me défendrai beaucoup un
diagramme c'est pas mon métier et je me
chanter c'est pas mon métier puma
réduisait de manière somme toute assez
candide mais on brandit comme massimo
c'est ça ta job
vas-y fais comme tu fais tes devoirs
après aller après les après les paroles
puis donne tous les outils d'une youtube
d'asseoir t'es payé pour chanter doute
lundi c'est un peu comme un ouais c'est
vrai le tifo arrêter le syndrome de
l'imposteur fait - partie 2 mois
maintenant si je m'excuse - d'exister
pour former à faire quelque chose s'est
calmée tué puis metz et s'étoffe laisser
aller ses affaires le setup ainsi ce
qu'il faut de l'expérience c'est là que
je réalise à quel point l'expérience et
et mieux puisqu'ils étaient des bonnes
journées des moins bonnes journées qui a
des fois tu va scorer d'autrefois papy
moi j'ai réalisé ici avec le temps à
quel point je me suis la première fois
que tu allais à la soirée est encore
jeune c'est en novembre 2016 il m'avait
présenté comme étant l'invité le moins
connu de l'histoire de la soirée est
encore juste avant ou des dames en eau
des savants des puits est en effet si je
n'ai pas connu le type piste et je ne
suis pas nerveux c'était à cette époque
leurs frais de saveurs est encore le
est effectif j'animais pas encore dit
s'il y apportant sa défensive mais
j'étais quand même un genre d'humour
jeunes lui montrer très jeune humoriste
et tai chi qui fait des jobs de son
secondaire sur ce qui s'est passé
pis
puis je me suis souvenu une dernière
fois que je suis allée où je me suis un
peu ça commença par un moment que ça
arrivera tôt mais paypal adam fois mais
la danse fautes que je t'ai chez roger
devant un public avec les autres un
hacker j'ai eu un moment qui est pas mon
type king avait été était différent et à
quel point j'étais meilleur à quel point
j'étais comme fetwa confiance puis avec
le temps aussi j'essaie de cangé
avez-vous checker les spéciales de
bobigny inside prend il a failli sortir
pendant la pandémie
puis il ya tout fait seul composé
thoniers écrit il ya enregistré il
réalisé il ya monté il ya rien qui a pas
fait de l'aide mais il y avait tout fait
j'observais c'était super inspirant
regardez à l'est puis plus jeune je
pense que je me serais 10h devrais-je je
t'aimerai savoir comment faire du
montage on dirait que dès que je voyais
quelqu'un faire quelque chose de bien je
me disais faudrait que je fasse comme
lui non mais là maintenant on dirait que
mountain king a changé observé sur ça
m'a inspiré de nos manières ou jetés
comme lui ai trouvé c'est quoi son
cadeau il l'a poussée à son maximum
moi c'est quoi mon cadeau qu'est ce que
moi je pose sur mon maximum ces puits le
sait plus ce que j'essaie de n'aurait
sais plus ce que j'essaie de faire
autant au des caillols cellou aussi
quand j'ai pas lyon des mets mon show
était déjà écrit veste est facile de
jump et de la tournée à od le g1 chaud à
écrire puis ça prend du temps c'est très
simple vinci c'est solide et le projet
c'est de faire ok j'ai signé une autre
saison c'est bien parfait j'ai observé
de suspect mais le le projet de 2022
c'est d'écrire un shoot c'est ce que je
veux le fond vous savez ça prend du
temps fait pour ce match comme belge
veut prendre une petite pause de télé be
puis créé
je retournerais une autre fois c'est pas
grave c'est ça s'est passé pas content
personne c'est pour moi l'idée de
sanctionner comme la chose la plus
évidente de l'histoire sauf que moi
c'est quelque chose que
je tiens au courant qui était un danger
j'étais au courant et nocif affirmé que
l'expérience le réalise à quel point cet
impact mais les six maximal mais se
compare aux autres la comparaison avec
les autres
c'est
compliqué laisser-aller soeur pour
devrait elle se dit souvent tu penses
que tu te compare pas aux autres mais
comparé quand même aux autres compare
aussi quelqu'un va avoir du succès sur
quelque chose plus votre voeu dans un
domaine qui connaît que soutient peloton
sera pas de sentir bien trop rare en
espèce de genre de petit sentiment
d'amertume par rapport à ceux où
quelqu'un va va avoir plus de succès
dans x ou y chante tu vas comme en voit
encore un espèce de petit feeling mais
ceux de laisser aller sur complètement
personnellement j'ai trouvé que ça
change tout ça va beaucoup de discipline
je pense que tu es quelqu'un de
discipliné - mais ça c'est pas facile ce
n'est pas facile mais c'est l'eau mais
je sais ce que tu dis ça résonne
beaucoup parce que
mes meilleures amies quand j'ai comme
figé parce que si je voulais dire
continuer à voler le si je radote le pas
ce que je fais je sors à d'autres
humains quand j'ai commencé à l'école de
l'humour mes amis c'était 4 levac les
meilleurs et ça me retombe et mehdi
boussaïd en les cédant qu'aux antilles
comme
s'étoffe le quand et pas super bon des
tchèques ces gens là mais j'ai aimé ça
que je n'ai pas de jaloux deux autres
mais j'étais juste comme quand lee ce
que je peux à leur niveau puis quand
j'arrivais d'un mort mais la money list
ramos à minuit au bordel à jouer après
louis josé puis moi j'étais comme ok
parfait si je me disais c'est la haye
pour des cotes changent mais je me
voyais comme un boxeur on va frapper les
côtes
puis outils simon leblanc débarquent des
commandes commando pour
celle au moyeu un temps où est
justement j'ai été trop influencée par
ce que j'ai observé que si j'écoutais le
show sur lequel j'ai été je voyais
quelqu'un vraiment énergie que je me
disais trop choix c'est ça ou jouer
quelqu'un j'ai palais parler de
politique
je parle de rien je voyais quelqu'un de
super quand j'étais enfant j'avais
peut-être essayer d'écrire aussi les
pyromanes et j'ai réalisé que les gens
embarquent est juste comme supporter le
linge de quelqu'un d'autre le type il ya
eu un temps un petit temps ça fait
longtemps le titan ou momentanément
j'écoutais pas les choses sur lesquelles
j'étais fait que je restais dans le jeu
puis les piges embarquer sur scène avec
aucune appréhension savait pas ce qui
s'était passé avant chaque épreuve qui
se passe après nécessairement ça a été
un petit moment à traverser puis après
ce qu'on dirait que ça m'a replacé le
ferai mais je vais être heureux peau
mes collègues sincèrement puis ce qui
est fascinant c'est que tu réalises à
quel point ça tu reviens quand tu es
quand tu es heureux pour les autres
quand tu es généreux avec les autres ça
tu reviens j'ai beaucoup de chèques et
de clips de jonny quinn qui animait le
tonight show à l'époque tout le monde le
considère comme étant le plus drôle
c'est john collins comme une légende
delumeau pis j'étais kipling clip we
parle vraiment pas beaucoup tes puisse
choquer comme animateur maintenant aux
animatrices quelque chose qui est super
bon comme qualité c'est la générosité si
c'est des de défendre la place pour ton
instit selon ses coaches au petit matin
porsche aux examens dispose se fait des
passes à palettes à l'autre personne
c'est pas pour toi mais curieusement ça
tu reviens
si tu fais de la place aux autres les
gens vont finir par enfin je trouve que
quand tu essaies de tirer la couverte de
ton boss qui nourrit pas la bonne
affaire ou si comme quand j'ai été
d'abord il ya beaucoup de gens qui je
débarque de 5mn tél j'ai pensé à
s'éjecter un but qui pourrait douter le
job c'est parfois des coups mais il m'a
quand même garder le compte ceci comme
si j'ai un siège un flash dans un motel
dit et puis ce garde fou je m'en fous tu
gardes forme et tout ça va tu revenir
mais en effet si top 6 et qu'ils fassent
trouve de vieillir un peu du moins de
maturer ou de prendre l'expérience il
prendre l'a1 aussi de la confiance en
soi parce que ça tu meurs quand même de
l'opo malti justement l'idée de faire
deux dirigeants je restais assise dans
l'oeuvre pas me comparer je vais pas
regarder les autres puis je veux refaire
ce que moi je vaux pis à voir le succès
que [ __ ] et moi je vaux je suis rendu
d'accepter au terran du type des fois
c'est ce qui était assez quand
souhaitait plus loin que été rendue
c'est une position inconfortable quand
j'aime recettes meilleures qu'est ce que
je suis mais non mais a précisé quand
même travail fait des shows faisant
mieux c'est pas grave mais accepte aussi
tombé mais des fossés nourrit la bonne
affaire a nourri c'est quoi ton affaire
c'est quoi ton cadeau qui se sert à rien
dans cette direction le pti mais le
sabre a aussi un peu de discipline je
pense c'est d'avoir la discipline de fer
et là je nourris pas la bonne affaire
moi je ne savais pas plus jeune je
comprenais pas quand les gens disaient
associés quelqu'un dans mr je comprends
les points qu'est ce que vous voulez
dire c'est quoi le sentiment d'amertume
ans avait posté quoi jusqu'à temps que
je commence à pas de l'humour les
journées j'en ai vu puis j'en ai déjà
ressenti quand j'ai les ressentis j'ai
détesté 100 meilleurs sentiments sur pn
sentiments et les j'ai fait je veux me
discipliner je vais pas me mettre dans
cette situation là mais je pense que je
suis quelqu'un de somme toute assez
discipliné c'est peut-être plus facile
pour moi de m'empêcher de checker des
trucs ou de faire attention à ce que je
fais mais avait apprécié avec le temps
ça change cessé d'évoluer c'est facile
aussi aujourd'hui quand mes trucs vont
somme toute assez bien de 2,2 0,7 mais
apprécié rien de plus de fun que de
cacher qu'un pierre yves roy des marais
qui sent son show pig m'ont dit que ces
malades cressier rien qui me réjouit
plus que si je sais que ça t'enlève rien
à toi la mallet veut rien puis c'est
cela faire moi j'ai appris ça en tournée
une drogue on ne sait pas si vous avez
déjà entendu puis peut-être que les gens
vous ont tissé par rapport aux podcasts
mais chic - à l'époque un beau coup de
parler on sait par une tarte la vente de
billets mettons deux mois maintenant six
ans plus tard puis comme c'est pas vrai
beau temps c'est pas vrai parce que moi
dans ma tournée il ya plein de gens qui
sont venus dont c'était le premier show
d'humour qui voyaient dans vie beaucoup
d'ados ou de jeunes adultes qui sont
venus voir mon spectacle il n'y avait
jamais vu de spectacle du monde de la
nuit qui vont aller voir un spectacle
existe à auby fonds est tellement le fun
c'était tellement une belle soirée
qu'est ce tu penses qu'ils font dans
certains que d'autres choses bougent
rive allemande autour du mot qui est 100
breton et d'enlever le cresson heaven en
douze mois
finalement c'est ça c'est pas une pointe
de tarte qu'on s'explique on cela
nourrit leur succès ces mots si nos
stars ben oui complètement je pense que
dans mon du podcast et la maintenance
sensiblement lille et moi j'ai vu le
lait est il on a vu le récemment les les
tops se laisse quand même on est souvent
des mêmes quelqu'un qui découvre le tien
découvre le nom quelqu'un découvre ou
redécouvre le tient plus et comme ça se
nourrit pee wee la précède tchèque le
studio sf trouvent les tic a mené si
seul ça nous enlève rien puis joe que
c'est si vrai dans dans beaucoup de
choses dans la vie pour juste dans nos
milieux respectifs prenant plein
d'autres affaires choquée la générosité
c'est quelque chose que tu reviens
tellement et c'est la pression j'ai
grandi dans une famille je pense comme
ça avec des fois c'est plus facile pour
moi de demander mais tout ça aussi mais
beaucoup nourri pis puis c'est ce même
mois tu vois ce cet été j'ai fait des
shows au bordel ça prend feu je faisais
des shows avec aucune pression pour vrai
j'ai pas besoin de faire du stand-up
j'avais juste le goût voilà seul le seul
moteur si les barres mêmes manques je
veux jouer j'avais pas tant de nouvelles
jo j'avais une coupe de nouvelles idées
finalement mme amy se dégrade mais jouer
avec aucune pression juste pour le fun a
soit je fais 12 minutes au bordel devant
soixante personnes si toutes ces puits
et c'était tellement le fun c'était
tellement le fun depuis sa première fois
que j'ai remarqué sur son décolleté
green day à les gens savent tissu que
j'ai du mot est ce qu'ils pensent puis
ultime entre le monde le monde je pense
à me laisser partir
ultima m'attend là c'est possible mais
on s'en fout là on s'en fout moi je
pourrais monter je pourrais le bordel je
pourrais monter ce stage faire un 12
minutes mettant ce serait sûrement pas
foule drôle sauf que le monde que choix
humoristes ou non je m'en coller je suis
déjà en train de faire 12 minutes de
blague c'est drôle comme ça drôle ou pas
après ce que je viens de où je fais quoi
on s'en cogne c'est ça tu es rendu le
tir et étienne athlètes ou t'es pas un
athlète parce qu'au dessus de contribuer
ainsi à ce moment tente encore en course
[Rires]
j'étais dans une bagarre une fois dans
ma vie puis aussi drôle la semaine
passée je suspecte des amis qu'on s'est
posé la question vous êtes vous déjà
battus à west et eu ce débat dessus ben
moi je mangeais pas j'ai pas vraiment
ça me fait penser à ça parce que c'est
exactement ce que tu dis puis c'est la
seule bagarre à laquelle j'étais sa
cause de lui le fond puis on a frôlé un
enterrement de vie de garçon
dans le garçon de nos amis aussi aux
bains douches là on était au sexe mania
toute l'équipe
les clichés en 2008 ok c'était cher tout
ces japonnais 2009
pis le ballon est trop long mais quatre
amis qui se mariait il s'était fait
dessiner des moustaches de shu par la
danse le style pas avec ses doigts elle
a deux grosses soirées ont surnommé le
docteur nos marges puccini en premi plus
choqué je veux c'est aider à reprendre
la route en dehors puis un gars qui
criait demande aperçue ayant réellement
d'un personnel qui mène ça on dénie ce
fameux sas mme
berra l'axé puis moi je ne sais pas
j'étais plus jeune j'étais plus gentille
en anti fumée était
déjà jaser avec beck un joueur en jalles
cepici beach il dit moi je gueulais la
parenthèse moi je trouve trop je
tenterai de commander au mcdo puisque
les rentes avec un de ses amis qui
reçoit un gros 1 son ami de keats
moubarak et rigueur y est en train de
dire à son ami qui filait pour se battre
cette soirée l'autre le mois puis fils
de 30 camions est en train de prendre
des commandes et des burgers et c'est
avec moi ça c'est le seul contact que
j'ai eu avec ses petits geluck a déjà un
petit peu petit pige en air frais je
fais que continuer tacler je me va jaser
avec lui tu sais c'est vraiment celle
permanent il fume ça tu es au petit pied
il ya le droit de fumer sein de
n'importe quelle adresse mais ça donne
envie puis il fait à moi j'ai arrêté de
fumer l'oeuvre le coma à deux semaines
plus je fais comme moussa boeck dans mon
cerveau les deux filles c'est le cas au
chemin n'ont rien à collo et tu fais
même date un fait mais il n'a pas arrêté
de fumer c'est l'énorme les rebelles
arrêtés ils font l'objet non ça marche
de tuffé ou de femmes politiques
c'est comme je sais pas qu'est ce qui
m'est passé par la tête de vouloir faire
la morale à un gars complètement chaud à
4 heures du matin mais georges penser
que c'est une bonne idée à ce moment là
dans la divine d'autre qu'un consorts
motif il convient d'entendre ça gueulait
dire qu'ils voulaient se battre cette
soirée l'homme on sort pile le ton monte
oui j'adore
ta gueule
mais ça en vaut bien ton nom j'ai
quelque chose à régler avec monsieur sy
site
génère c'est comme ça sommes
complètement il s'est quand même c'est
finalement à mes gens ont réussi à
prendre deux hommes pierre alfort parti
philippe guèye à manicamp stan s'était
lui aussi donné comme le ton monte
putois tacler lui rentrer dedans puis
bros son ami du loup je me fais mien
c'est d'ailleurs bien dangereux que ça
que je les revois les 200 vienne
historique d'aubin craint qu'il est ok
on s'en va les gars on savait que les
autres marche rapide on s'en veut pileux
il y avait la moitié de la gagne qui est
encore dans le mac do quittant maria
harti fois que l'on sort tourner pilote
allemand le gros bras qui vit que pour
réussir me rattraper il n'y a pas ni mon
frère pigeon non il le tabac
de rené laurin bishop pascale lecam en
train de scier le frère de dom le groupe
essaie de rattraper double parce qu'elle
essaie quand même de courir pour essayer
d'aller commentent les deux piquant qui
arrive à sa hauteur l'orgueil stone tac
il tend ap ap le le temps qu'on arrive
il y en a donné un bon 5 6 bonnes
mais après ça ça comme un peu ça c'est
comme
[Musique]
le relève qu il s excuse toi gumbo
article que j'avais que j'avais bien dit
il les textures je m'excuse mais je
rends désolé
j'ai tout passé un parent tenons au
point chaque
lot à tous notre ami avec les moustaches
de choc a répété en retard de type c
comme lui de calmer le jeu le clou c'est
le chemin des
filets maria régulation mais tellement
ce qu'ont fait les affaires non c'était
aussi un défi
le plus c'est que on parlait de tout
justement je me bats avec mes amis puis
c'est vraiment à faire je trouve de
jeunesse dans le sens où je me suis pas
battu dans la ville apportant le support
puissions signer source d'un art mûr
c'est super gore et rex fera avec des
gants puis cassé comme vu les épées
l'état mais aujourd'hui
je suis vraiment rendu au psg dans
l'ouest qui est arrivé de common et je
suis suis à l'hôtel puis il y avait un
sauna l'hôtel fait que souvent quand je
revenais du jim houda course j'allais
dans le sauna et après ce je pense qu'on
allait rapidement donc au lieu de
remonter à ma chambre prendre ma douche
j'ai juste utiliser la douche du
vestiaire il le vestiaire est somme
toute assez petit à l'hôtel pis il ya
une douche puis nous savons dans l'eau
je me lave les douches et le chanteur
quelqu'un rentrée par action de ce type
dans le puits
et après genre 30 secondes j'entends le
guet enfin comme en
2d ce cas le mets dans ma tâche commence
à des trains par ex on finira par là moi
je réponds cours mais y être pire dit
quelque chose je fais
10 mai jean rémy oui oui
j'ai jusqu'à moi pas parler à quelqu'un
comme suspect je devrais prendre ma
douche on a deux filles pauvres et pas
longue car c'est 35 ans le je suis ni je
me suis je sors je vois qui a tant fait
les choses comme un
pilier vraiment choqué le cam yann et
puis j'ai été apprécié ce qui était
drôle c'est que le banc où peu de gens
étaient tellement petit qu'on était
vraiment les deux raconté degré très
proches l'un de l'autre et les tendances
bien beau
mais ça devrait ça m'a tellement ça m'a
tellement marqué tellement désagréable
même interactions humaines puis après
jetée comme pas déçu de mon match
j'aurais aimé ce avec justin gatlin qui
fait rêver
n'habite même pas prétentieux vraiment
juste sincère il devait revoir une
mauvaise journée pauvres et où c'est
peut-être quelqu'un de malheureux ou je
sais pas quoi il peut juste plus
impatients wadhwani mais juste gérer
mais ce il renvoyer quelque chose de
plus doux que jusqu'à un cours de
politique
je n'ai pas crié j'ai pas je me suis
papou nié avec mais je t'ai cup by on
dirait que la semence et qu'on parle et
se débattait comme j j'ai pas mettons
que ça ça une altercation
chacun méfie toi qui t'y la dernière
chose que je sais c'est comme des
coutumes ainsi que des votes deux
personnes se battre c'est vraiment
jamais brillé non vraiment injuste n'y
ai jamais vu quelque chose intelligente
il ya personne faisait nager bataille
elle me garder ce passera comprendre il
j'avais raison de force il me coupe et
c'est qu'il n'y aura jamais jamais
jamais pertinent
ok je sais pas apprécié jeudi en
s'entendant si quelqu'un essaie de faire
mal à un monde de ma fatigue légitime
défense
plus d'un
ce qui suit nous avons toujours jeter
avec goethe avec un dieu qui me parlait
d'un il fait un trip d'ayahuasca
l'ouest avec le dit bernard pis puis moi
ce qui me fascine dans ce puits les gens
que je connais car non fait je leur pose
la question parce que moi je l'amusant
comprendre mettons le monde qui parle de
ces balles qui ont eu un déclic s'est
fait que moi concrètement c'est quoi le
déclic lui même expliquait justement la
semaine passée que le déclic précis
qu'ils avaient eue c'était qui perdait
plus jamais patience il dit parce que
y'a comme compris dans son triple dans
son ancien voyage l'astral que
qu' il pouvait pas se mettre en place
des gens fait qu'il s'est passé quoi
leur journée il s'est passé quoi qui
vivent à ce moment là elle s'est pas
fait lui il m'expliquait que maintenant
maintenant on était capable d'être dans
son short planeta lumière rouge mettant
plus en avant lui qui la lumière tombe
et le char bougent peu je suis capable
d'attendre que la lumière retourne rouge
et retourne verte avant de faire un
action de jean reçoit klaxonné ou me
frustrer c'est parce que je ne sais pas
est en train de faire quoi ce sont
celles en avant peut-être sa mère est
malade qui peut-être que wade veut
raison je veux pas que l'actionnaire je
veux pas me mettre la pression sur ce
pays je vois pas être impatient revers
subis j'ai quand cette crise c'est un
complice en faisant un très bon c'est
quand même triste way
le presse et je trouve que les claques
sont jeunes utilisent vraiment pas sur
la voiture mais c'est parce que ses
agresseurs et agressés mais ces projets
j'en rêve jusqu'à ton juste juste pour
taton attention à
notre sens
c'est ça je crois que c'était toi c'est
quelque chose à ce que vanessa pilon est
venu sur mon podcast puis hamon a
compris
qu'elle a fait la paix avec la mort
c'est pas peur des crises non mais comme
accepter la mort ouais c'est comme un
fait qu un peu la craie avec ce terme la
mort de lego cas le vécu puis après ce
avec un accepter que l enfant la vie
c'est ce que c'est ça puisqu'ils donnent
sa pertinence à la vie aussi c'est le
fait qu'elle se termine bien calé comme
accepter la mort d'homme waouh il serait
robinet cet avantage il peut écouter
j'ai compris une pause
why abl
est ce que vous écoutez
en ping-pong
super humoriste un gars vraiment
vraiment coup de pied plus justement
dans l'introspection plus y reçut chris
martin le chanteur de
ces super entre autres puits
puis bref un login et un dernier paquet
ce que j'avais vraiment apprécié c'était
j'oublie son nom soudainement seulement
c'est un autre humoriste ses amis
s'est
enrichie au nord-est de new york j'ai
fait un peu plus un peu plus tard ce
puits lui pendant la pandémie est partie
et c'est en équateur est allé habiter le
pendant plusieurs mois puis a fait un
trip d'ailleurs à ce que la boe et il
raconte à la fin de ce podcast avec la
danse folk et ali raconte tout son trip
puis raconte qu'à manille
bon il a été malade il y avait une
ceinture devant le feu puis son ami tête
l'autre côté du feu puis il y avait deux
charmants avec le kit est comme vous
vivent chacun votre tribu qui avaient
chacun leur charmante petite surprise
d'allemagne est assis dans le fût
billetech com j'ai essayé de parler mes
parents ses parents sont décédés
ça peut marcher puissamment et essayer
de parler à la propriété comme une
histoire qui est une grande figure dans
l'humour américain mes t-shirts qui est
comme la mère de daman spirituel de bain
des humoristes parce que comme
d'histoire c'est quelque chose de ce
puits lui même et elle était très très
généreuse pour l'ups heures puis flamand
est apparu devant lui ai dit et on
parler puis comme je sais comment ça
sonne je sais de quoi j'ai leur âge en
gesticulant danseurs
mais c'est arrivé je peux pas vous le
dire autrement que comme moi bien
précieux il s'est étendu par terre puis
il ya des espèces de globe ce genre qui
sont comme sortis de lui puis ont été
vers le ciel il y en a deux qui sont
sortis puis les globes représentés et
comme c'est quand
tu accomplis des cadeaux maintenant tu
es gift
pis que la réception la main qu'ils
expliquent les jeunes explique mans sur
un moment j'ai quitté mes enfants et
comme c'est comme si la raison de la
qualité sur terre quand tu réussis à
accomplir quelque chose lui mettons
cette es16 ainsi show était comme ce
matin j'étais à mon plein potentiel
pissas le rendu des gens heureux
c'était comme un globe pilote était un
show télé que fait kick ou vestes et des
anecdotes puis ça fait que ça peu
fashion et ses collègues qui venaient
faire des anecdotes sur son shoot
ellipses atteint et piétiste remonte
enfin vous mes cadeaux puisque ça peut
faire pour les autres ça c'est comme
rencontrées par ailleurs excellent tim
de raison que de leur exacte de
compresseurs compresseur et finalement
lui qui avait réalisé après ça c'est que
leurs enfants chants quête de
mai globe gentil je vais me concentrer
sur ce jeu met mes énergies va les
choses ou moi je vends mon plein
potentiel pis ça peut aider les autres
d'une autre manière puis je vois c'est
quand même intéressant comme
constatations dans les maisons c'est une
scène
je pense vraiment qu'ils étaient ça peu
d expérience que
la foi qui mijote en dedans de toi ça
sort pas de ce pôle univers lancé qui
s'arrêtent de sampo du ciel à l'embarras
biennale de danse qu'esquisse kidjo le
geste peut que ça le manifeste que tu
réalises de quoi ça j'en suis convaincu
qu'on en parlait avec levier là on a
reçu le pharmacien pour passer parce que
sa deuxième saison balado porte sur les
walker qui
puis comme on en parlait de cdc ans
assisté avec des psys avec un dosage
qu'on connaît pas dans un affaire loin
de tout les hôpitaux puis ou est ce que
tu sais de quoi vraiment charme semble
que moi c'est sûr je sais charge près
seuls ses surgelés serré / / / critique
des lieux où est ce que c'est vraiment
plus justement sur les lieux les
salaires des quelque chose foule
anticapitaliste pitié mais en réalité
une distance entre deux feux le cash
c'est le gars qui étaient sur le chaman
ce n'est pas nécessairement une espèce
de singe c'est jordan
17 ans qui était jorion milieu parce que
ça ne prend jamais
cessé c'est pas nécessairement aussi
romantique pub aux pigeons que qu'on le
pense le tiercé mais la substance en
tant que tel oui ça peut être dangereux
à la briquette drogue c'est surtout que
le dosage est pas contrôler non mensuel
mais avec un dosage contrôler dans des
paramètres contrôlés c'est sûr je serai
c'est de plus en plus besoin d'en parler
de plus en plus réétudier mettant ses
limites et savait qu'on était quand même
gardé de lyzel du cir jeunes en général
puis le maintenant c'est comme de retour
sur la table comme vraiment quelque
chose de neuf venue possible béton
poreux pour guérir je pense que comme
n'importe quoi ces gens d'affaires qui
n'est peut-être pas pour tout le monde
c'est justement mon chien tolérants aux
morts mais il faut pouvoir je sais pas
pourquoi mon corps pour voilà je pense
que c'est la même chose ce genre de truc
que justement tu sais si c'est ce qui se
passe avec les drogues j'écoutais
justement des pots cassés des gens qui
sont comme tout devrait être légal
puisque ont presque doublé vienne
puisqu'ils veulent dit en termes
d'ajustement mais pour que les drogues
soient de meilleure qualité pour et
c'est justement à vancouver dans l'ouest
le maine le fentanyl people who you
j'avais jamais vu
de drogue se prendre comme si c'était le
cas il ya des quartiers à côté d'un
quartier est plein
comme auch laxisme okla connue de tous
elle savait rien et c'est à cause d'eux
comment ça coûte cher vivent là que si
t'as pas l'argent tu es vraiment dans un
ghetto complets et exacts pour plein de
raisons je pense aussi le tilt à la côte
ouest comme différent mais aussi bien
puisque
voyait déjà se piquer sur la rue le tcd
ses décors et maison complété en ville
où c'est un jeu subtil des piqueries à
ciel ouvert jusque là justement c'est
avec ces assistés pour que ce soit plus
clint mais c'est un problème lancé sur
pc que mac et ben si c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment un ticket c'est vraiment
spécial tout ce gibier tellement
complexe le tir une question qui nuance
et en synchro mais oui mais oui mais oui
mais tout ce qui est
ces deux pistes de connaissance de soi
ou de réflexion d'introspection sont
aussi assister ouais c'est quelque chose
d'assez intéressant moi je trouve ça
même si je trouve ça vraiment guérir et
oui
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on soit jeune
[Musique]
qui va se décaler vers l'est un petit
peu le et
[Applaudissements]
c'est cool ça comme question j'aime tout
le temps se met le suivant je sais pas
pourquoi quand on pose ces questions le
très souvent la première fois qu'il
vient en tête c'est
la paix pour la paix par rapport aux
autres mais une espèce de pain térieur
justement un peu comme quand je me sens
agitée de de trouver les moyens de à
douter capable de faire ce justement le
sport me mettre beaucoup à ce type de
bien manger bien dormir avant le temps
d'écrire des trucs fakir être en paix à
l'intérieur
mais sinon je pense je vous demanderai
de la création d'une créativité on
envoie le dieu la création joël
ce que je veux plus d'assumer ce de dd
dans le le plaisir puis l'amusement le
secret des blagues dans le grand plaisir
est-ce que tu t'imagines
parce que le top a encore vécu un hiver
dans ta maison comme elle est maintenant
le rénover maintenant tout le kit
l'install il s'imagine dessus à ton
bureau ce qu'on a vu son bureau il y met
sur la cour extérieure comme j'imagine
la gueuse mais avec un trader d'une
machine à écrire qui regardent la mer
qu'on mettra qu'il m'a vu que deux trois
buts dans le foyer le
show du mot ouais ça risque ça c'est la
vision romantique
et c'est le souhait en pratique je sais
pas ça va voir là mais tout ça commence
en gaspésie avec david bocage on veut
souvent l'argent - sa famille une maison
là-bas puis enfin qu'on veut jouer au
hockey au village de mario puis on écrit
des jo et puis on n'est que des films
puis on lit des livres puis on fait
d'abord parce que je pense le
kickstarter est en janvier c'est ce que
je souhaiterais et commence à écrire le
matériel qu'ils apprécient oui ça va se
passer beaucoup à maison mais c'est
aussi tout juste passé mais j'ai pas
beaucoup de chilly chez nous dans ville
j'ai le juste faire comme élevé puis
passer deux jours de suite je sais nous
essayer de cuisiner puis fac et ça c'est
le souhait mais ces sujets comme excitée
d'être jugés jamais aussi écrit un chien
chaud en étant conscient que j'ai créé
un show c'est un premier show sur les
crises entendu quand l'accumulation de
la zac le caecum bah ouais je sais que
je vais écrire c'est quand même vraiment
un autre affaire mais on dirait que je
veux vraiment être dans la plaie
fournissait vraiment dans la créativité
soit plus amuse toi avec sortie puis
d'accepter le processus mais mon
processus il la c4 levac à la sortie un
choix les crises super vite il est
vraiment bonne ça ses six premières
versions sont très solides bien précieux
a modifié un peu mes premières versions
sont très faibles mais je les modifier
énormément fac-ci juste d'accepter ce
que je ne dois pas te fonctionne demain
pour vous qu'est ce qu'on vous souhaitez
vous
qu'est ce qu'on nous souhaite qu est ce
qu ont ensuite
choisi
la paix la paix c'est parti à
l'intérieur le sentiment d'être
des outils doit être d'être en phase
avec le sida fait en fait c'est
d'accepter les moments d'agitation puis
de trouver les moyens de les calmer
c'est ce que j'aime aussi d avoir un peu
plus d'expérience que j'en avais des
trois là je me sens même
plus capable soit de l'exprimer maxime
est on j'arrive le matin on va déjeuner
les 300 billets être a pas de bouder les
légumes récente maman juste que vous
nommez web ça enlève des jeunes bus de
dans le foot il faut qu'ils aient tout
souci je trouve dans la dans la quête de
la paix intérieure c'est qu'ils vont
avoir des moments d'agitation c'est
normal ça va pas arrêter mais d'abord de
trouver les moyens qui fonctionne pour
toi c'est moi suivant cc cambrai le lot
justement faut que j'aie corée
correspond comme s'entraîner dans le
gymnase james inhofe je peux être mon
slip secourir non leur sang prend une
heure pour aller chez mes parents si mal
et ça c'est notre en un sens il
la maison puis juste
et
[Musique]
autres vacances moi je rentre et je me
sens complètement
brûlés de la ninja complet on dirait que
c'est comme si je te disais ticket que
ce matin georges grenier dont on album
sur lequel georges travail comme depuis
vraiment vraiment longtemps c'est qu'il
n'y a rien de vraiment me diot fini
aussi les podcasts dans le midi on
tourne à donner podcast après ce petit
vent des vacances et le siamois qui est
moins que les variants ne permettent pas
aux jeux para thaïlande en mode janvier
j'aurai envie de faire du bien et puis
très cool moi je pense que ça t'a
bruisse est un bon comme moi je me sens
vraiment comme complètement
vidé que j'avais quand même bout du
rouleau pied de l'intérieur je pense que
j'ai besoin d comme pas travailler
pendant comme un bonbon juste comme
vivre jusque sommes remplis pu laisser
les choses venir c'est chose monter le
seul l'inspiration monter les styles
comme la curiosité c'est drôle je sais
pas si c'est l'âge à laquelle on est
rendu à ce que la plupart des gens que
je côtoie sont sensiblement notre âge
mais il ya beaucoup de gens autour de
moi et je m'inclus la dent qui ont cédé
0 un homme né comme barredo et vivre la
vie un peu restée un mois sans pour ça
ça vaut 100
m aux jo on était dans
une soirée que les miens la blonde je me
rends compte que ja si on parle pas de
dormez temps de musées coûté 2 ou 2 ou
de discussion connaissance les podcasts
plus de maîtres de débats sociaux
d'affaires de même genre
par l'idée genre je sais pas quoi le
monde parle de soirée jean plus j'arrive
comme avec les chaumes de l'ami des plis
terrain moi je suis travaille dans tel
ou tel domaine plus comment - puis le
genre audric
comme parler de la vie parler de la vie
genre de truc
noter les heures de sport par les gens
dresser ici comme ça
c'est georges andré carrel goudé comme
justement allez pouvoir parler de de
cuisine avec 1go dans un parti que je
connais pas piquer comme je vais tenir
cette semaine qui est georges essayer ce
puits gentil parler de trucs fois car
l'outil quelque peu juste de genre de
la dernière controverse au québec où
j'avais
acquis au sujet du coup de com des
devis un petit plus en demande plus
normalement pu m'intéresser à qom dès 10
heures plus plus du quotidien du jour au
jour le jour genre plus les spéciales
c'est qu'avec le métier qui pratiquent
ces genres de vie où tu peux choisir des
moments où on est neuf et un peu plus
mais quand justement tu sors d'une passe
ou d'une décennie où tu as travaillé
très fort justement aller chercher cette
liberté leurs défunts mais je peux
prendre un mois offre c'est comme il
faut comme rebâtir nos réflexes
ils m'ont dit tu vois l'hiver passé j'ai
pris off pendant un petit bout de temps
après ça c'était pas en mx était somme
toute assez confortable guillemets dame
de neupro 9 et avait pas de show il mais
il ya plein d'affaires là dedans c'est
apprendre je me surpris avant le goût
d'aller bûcher du bourg au piton
mongazon printemps puis pour rennes
c'est vraiment ressources en même temps
ils ont raison il est très satisfaisant
j'ai commencé mes feuilles qui sait
combien je tombe dit c'est juste mais
oui le tyran le projet de faire un phare
de quad gamins sont cool tu es cuisine
et un plongeur qui suivent la recette
pour réussir
mais moi j'avais luthiste n'est pas
quelque chose que je faisais je prenais
portant de faux noms mais c'est
tellement satisfaisant mais le tubage
récemment j'essaie de me remettre dans
une situation où j'ai réalisé que fait
longtemps que j'ai essayé quelque chose
de nouveau je n'ai aussi jeune de 30 ans
pour arrêter d'apprendre que je comme on
dirait que j'aimerais sur puis moi je
sais aussi que j'ai des difficultés à
poursuivre quelque chose auquel je suis
pas bon relativement rapidement puis le
ch comme à québec j'aimerais ça
commençait à essayer ne serait-ce qu'une
affaire
puisse perdurer un peu dedans c'est
comme le sexe que ce soit des cours de
piano à 6 lits dont je sais pas quoi le
mes frere le rat toi au point où ça va
être le fun comme donne toi aussi tu
mens la d re commencer à redonner un
étudiant arrêté je trouve que je l' ai
beaucoup étaient mélangés que ça fait un
moment que ça me manque puis comme noisy
à voter au toit plus à tout le tsl
les affronte le tout livré son cri
qu'il faut que je fasse un mécanisme est
en
jeu c'est non mais je
suis là où je veux être moi quand même
c'est comme
je pense que j'ai
mon amie ma femme ma carte du ciel
récemment puis c'est une fille bien
gentil qui m'envoyait un document audio
ou à me raconte ma carte du ciel pis je
t'ai pas pour ni contre jeter comme
juste curieux jeu très ouvert puis au
début à le dire comme si je t'invite à
écouter ça avec ouverture mais aussi
t6 à des trucs qui fait pas avec toi
bateau peut exulter puis puis bref à
l'expliquer comme en même temps ma
carrière est vraiment au coeur de mon
être c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'important je pense que je les ai
constaté dans les dernières années puis
ça fait quand même un moment que ça fait
quelques temps que j'ai réalisé avec
l'achat de ma maison j'ai réalisé à quel
point comme le je voulais j'ai beaucoup
nourri ma carrière puis je continue de
le faire pis ça me remplit pas ça me
rend heureux puisque ça fait que je me
dépense puis j'ai cet affable suspens
mais de plus en plus ma vie personnelle
je la nourrit aussi de l'heure pour moi
mettons la course fait partie des trains
le gicam et j'aimerais se courir un
marathon ça va pas me ramener d'argent
ça va pas me ramener de faim moodagent
et c'est pourquoi c'est juste pour moi
je veux me dépasser moi physiquement
pour mon mental pour mon corps pour voir
et veut bien précises avec les mêmes
débuts à long terme avec swisscom mais
je pense qu'un ironman et va un jour
dans plusieurs années c'est quelque
chose que je pense à mme andrée moins
heureux de remplir
est-ce qu il fallu que je fasse le
centre bell puis cinq saisons daudet
pour parler comme ça vous n'êtes
peut-être que oui peut-être que non je
sais pas mais je le mets ma maison il ya
subtil ya un espèce de désir de com mais
oui je me suis clean et mon bois en
argent et puis j'aimerais apprendre à
faire une coupe d'europe cette puce gps
que je prends des cours de piano
peut-être je sais pas deux fois
piano chez vous un piano chez nous
maintenant le cefac mais j'aurai plus de
temps qu'à ce qu'ils soient là juste là
pour la déco oui mais ces foules
inconfortable pour moi c'est super
important mais je trouve le confort dans
l'inconfort ses puits dans le sport pour
moi c'est plus facile de trouver le
confort dans l'inconfort alors que dans
des pubs en piano ça va mieux si je le
sais je le cède avance va être gêné dans
le projet mais c'est comme tout c'est de
les gaules c'est comme enlève tout seul
non sans poils berhad fera chier toute
ta vie si tu veux on sent qu ils
essayent juste bien moustoir et puis à
nier qu'il qui le quitte il faut que
j'aie fax et saint andré que j'essaie
juste de je pense pas que j'ai besoin de
m'évader
mais je sais que j'ai envie de la vie
est très très grande puis évidemment que
les loges puis les spectacles piles et
les preuves et les affaires de tout seul
c'est super le fun mais ce n'est qu'une
partie de la grosse affaire exact exacte
des
voyages et ses super pu voyager t'as pas
besoin d'aller loin c'est allé courir à
tremblant de 17 ans tout puissant mais
rentre et je prends je vois aller faire
c'est bientôt la pelle mois mais oui on
ironisé tout seul allez prendre le temps
de jeu pour un grand organisateur si je
te paraît sûre pour justement si je vais
organiser des choses organiser des
affaires mais pour ma vie percée des
sorties d'amis dé je vois pas pis je
trouve que mon organisme surprise cet
été pour mes 30 ans avant que je passe
puis j'ai constaté à quel point ce thème
c'était fréquent dans ma vie que
beaucoup de gens faisait beaucoup
d'efforts pour me rendre heureux
j'ai dit et j'ai eu des rentes avec de
l'univers où ce que dit sa peau de steve
bon sens au démon fait des surprises à
tous et saison presque
et là mes amis ma famille mon fait
surprise
il y en a eu en eux il y en a eu sa pas
d'alluré l'amour comme mon frère et puis
des soirées où j'étais ce qu'on
célébrait
les mains
j'ai fini ce soir et leurs suppôts du
feu avec ma mère
j'étais comme si quand la danse fois que
moi j'ai fait ça pour quelqu'un
puisse comme j'ai fait des bonnes
actions franches comme je quelqu'un qui
donne piqué généreux mais aujourd'hui je
me suis dit aïe je veux faire ce jutra
personne tu es en a qui ont plus de
facilité que d'autres à organiser des
surprises des fêtes où
messi somme toute relative ça suffit
tout le monde est capable de le faire
c'est là que je suis comme on dirait que
je vais te donner plus aux règles du jeu
recevoir à la maison si j'ai une belle
hausse totale
c'est tellement le fun c'est puis je
pense que je lis cette affaire j'ai
grandi dans une famille que quand je
demandais si mon ami prévenir su rester
tout le temps oui c est qu on vote on va
falloir de la pi 10 po grave et oui oui
oui fac et on savait que les cheveux
nourrir ce plus puis je veux je veux je
pense aussi que depuis le début aussi de
membres mon métier est tellement
égocentré quitter c'est tellement moi
qui fais des affaires puis qui fait du
bruit puis des dans votre monde quitte
applaudi ce qu'ils disent que tf1 ou je
sais pas quoi c'est super c'était lequel
chance mais c'est aussi moi j'ai très
peur de pas me rendre compte que j'ai
tout mis du inconsciemment à l'homme que
c'est quand même en faut dans un jeu
vraiment être conscient de ce que le
monde reste je veux être plus de l'autre
bord
tu as fait trop de sentiments toi qu'est
ce qu'on souhaite ph
moi j'ai l'impression d'être un chien
dans une pièce le qui cherche son spot
pour s'installer bâton pour de vrai le
pur dormir pour la nuit mais va se
prendre les valeurs phares or il faut
pousser genre un coup vers plymouth
polop les vallées proche plus proche de
la fenêtre parce qu'il fait plus frais
plus violentes ou de la porte parce
qu'il ne courant d'un plan précis de
trouver sa place pour dormir de la nuit
mais je me sens comme lol je pense qu'on
souhaite de trouver mon spot
géographiquement mais dans mon endroit
où est ce que je vais pouvoir dire ça
ici
c'est la maison c'est ici c'est là que
je vois m'installer ouais mais la
géographie est une chose mais
[Musique]
ton spot
transpo this in mais ton mental
l'impression que
que tu le trouve je pense que je pense
qu'elle la trouve vraiment ce qu'il fait
on s'est vraiment mes tantes et on a
parlé hier pitite comme une année record
avec la mollesse qui recueille boulistes
raquette puis je la presse un des
derniers mois même tu te sens crissement
plus relax qui se ment plus ouverts aux
en plus ce
genre - - dans les extrêmes de rien
vraiment plus ce chiffre en plus dans
nos faire n'importe quoi c'est spécial
aussi parce que des fois on se sent très
alignés et c'est sur notre xx août on al
impression que l aile ça m'est arrivé
relativement récemment faire ben oui le
sud ça marche c'est le goût de rien
changé c'est comme quand tu veux faire
le ménage si vous luttez commenté je
veux pas cuisiner que son père moniteur
n'est pas en 2d classique un moyen c'est
redevenu salles partout j'ai rien fait
pour tout petit c'est ce qui est bizarre
en revanche trop ce qui
s'est vraiment cyclique ça se promènent
puis des fois t'es comme un aimant tout
fait sens puis du jour au lendemain
c'est comme pourquoi le soudainement pu
céder ça a été si l'apprentissage c'est
de faire même quand
tout semblait ta bonne place le
sentiment par rapport à la piedra
changer de toutes les peintures east
couleur puis à mener c'est comme chris
la couleur ces puces l1 tu sais pas
pourquoi c'est aussi qui est fascinant
de la vie sexy comme on trouvera jamais
la réponse tout à fait à votre tout le
temps et on veut tout le temps est en
train de se replacer en sorte de se
réaligner puis ce que ce que j'entends
dans ce que tu dis aussi c'est que
il ya quelque chose c'est important
aussi d'être bien chez soi mais je vais
les chercher longtemps puis longtemps ça
m'a pas dérangé en fait on ne pas être
bien chez nous j'aime chez nous c'est
mon chargeur est ce ça m'allait pilot
mais depuis que j'ai la maison j'ai
juste hâte de me déposer le puis je sais
que ça va me faire du bien ok je te
souhaite vraiment vraiment il ya quelque
chose puis
quelque chose que jean philippe sert de
la cuisine de jean philippe llech et un
chef rêver quand j'étais déçu mais avec
la semaine passée puis m'expliquer un
concept lui il est gros dans le
bouddhisme puis dans lequel puisqu'il
philosophie orientale par admettons le
feng shui ces choses là pour commerces
installés ton espace puis m'expliquer
que toutes ces études ces idées là
s'applique mal au québec parce que c'est
pas le climat pluie est tombée sur une
affaire qui s'appelle le jeu supportera
bien prononcé le mélo ig h y ge qui est
un second concept scandinave de désarmer
ton et il m'expliquait que les eagles
étaient mettons le summum du higuain
c'est d'être sur un divan chaud avec une
tasse de café devant un feu avec un mur
vitré sur une tempête de neige ne tombe
ce c'est comme le summum le tchèque
genre la chaleur dans malgré la
température puis expliqué que ce concept
le au québec
si le concept dans un chalet dans le
fond le tri c'est un concept qui est
vraiment facilement applicable dans
notre vie parce que nous autres c'est ça
tout le temps quasiment le trailer il
fait il fait nuit à 4 heures il va faire
froid puis dit la eagle une bonne façon
de trouver ton chez vous le c ce temps
chez vous tue-le tue-le
iguiniz qu'il soit confortable soit
confortable comme sauter comme ceux peu
comme on est posée plus à quel point la
partie et 0 eagles à
0 eagle mai mais ouais ça c'est comme un
concept que je pense que je vais essayer
de me trouver une place en
ligue 1 mais oui on sait c'est fascinant
c'est juste la quête de calme puis de
bien être et l'équilibré entre et qu'est
ce qui est excitant qu'est ce qui est
typique d'avoir les moments où un moment
hors de tout trouver cet équilibre est
mal en cela cette fine balance vient
complémenter puis c'est
s'il s'agit d'une vie c'est vrai ça
c'est tout le temps tout le temps en
mouvement ce thème et je te le souhaite
je souhaite vraiment merci beaucoup puis
merci du prévenu on se refait sa à la
traditionnelle décembre après aux dés
j'aime tout ça c'est un jour un extrême
plaisir plaisir partagé les garçons tous
les gars ça tout le temps quand à
nouveau merci meunier a à du contenu
excellent tu as tout un podcast convient
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur une pétillante le pitch vous abonner
pour trop de leur part mais aussi trop
de la whey trois pièces par morlaàs par
mois ils avaient les pattes carte en
avance acquise avec les premiers de
votre groupe d'amis à vous écouter les
podcasts qu'ils allaient avoir pouvoir
avoir une avance quand vous allez tirer
la dynamique entre les amis tout le
temps avons une avance sur les jobs en
avance ou juge entre le toit mais avec
pétillante une avance sur l'humanité
complète en plus en plus parce que leur
chèque le podcast su ni voulu me tendant
jazz ou davantage on fait des encore
moins de filtres à préchac podcast avec
là on vient de finir de tourner le
podcast on va en jaser on va t'il et
nicole non nicole il est maintenant
évident comme le fit le travail la place
de taza taille est là mais on jase on
parle de conversion qu'on m'aide à voir
mais ce si vous voulez avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous s'est excusé
sur pétule il faut s'abonner abonnez
vous